during the riots last year
there was a man it's a brutal story i
gotta be honest there was a man who was
attending to his bar
there's a group of people who are
smashing windows this guy goes out
his name was jake gardner they attack
his dad
and then he tells him to back off he
shows them that he's got a gun
one guy attacks him gets him on the
ground is choking him
this dude fires in self-defense
initially
the uh prosecution said the prosecutors
the county said that it was
uh the self-defense but then the
protesters came out
and there were threats of riots and this
i think it's interesting this this is
very much a precursor to what we saw
with chauvin we need to pay attention to
this stuff
because of the protesters and because of
the threats of riots and the fear of
violence and damage
they decided to actually criminally
charge this guy who was on the ground
being choked
who was defending himself who had warned
this group this group who was riding
the guy ended up taking his own life and
now we have an exclusive story from tim
cast he is filing
his family sorry is filing a wrongful
death suit arguing
that the the defendants in the case
conspired
to deprive him of his rights we need to
pay attention to things like that
because one ended up
what ended up happening with chauvin one
of the jurors came out and said
i feared retaliation they'd come to my
house these jurors were being escorted
in the building with
armed police because of the riots and
the violence not too far from the court
one of the jurors actually lived
where riots were currently occurring now
there's real concern over what might end
up happening
with the equipment with the trial of uh
cal rittenhouse
so we're gonna get into this we'll talk
a lot about what's going on with that
we've got a protest that happened
outside of the white house
because you got a lot of people who want
the want the us government to intervene
to help cuba
plus we've got uh joe biden just losing
his
absolute mind and we're getting into it
so uh joining us today
is one of the foremost experts on the
protest and the riots over the past you
know year or so is rachel mcginnis
foremost i like that word i mean bro i
don't know about you
but foremost i like foremost expert you
were at almost every single major i was
at the front
i was foremost i don't know foremost
yeah yeah you're literally
you have no idea what's going on the
whole time but you're just standing
there like
i'm in the front wide angle no no let's
let's be real i mean
every time there's a big major breaking
story around these riots or what's
happening you were there
and then we'd have you come on and you
talk about what happened and so yeah man
foremost expert actually
my co-worker shout out to vin's colonies
um
and i'll just do a quick plug for vince
and jason save the nation our new show
on daily caller anyways um he said that
i forrest gumped the year
and i thought i thought that was kind of
funny because forrest gump kind of just
like happened to be at all these events
you know you just kind of stumbled
through it and that's kind of how i felt
which is just like
we were just kind of going on hunches
the whole time i've got to do it we
don't normally do this but someone just
super chatted us right now
and it's big and it's um what is it
leguma thighgeon or whatever but they
said jaffa
cree ian cree and shout out for the
stargate reference because i've been
watching
mad stargate lately and uh you know so
anyway welcome richie we got eeny's
chilling what's up everybody
ian jafakari jafakri did it changing
stargate going on this last year you
don't speak stargate
you want to learn not yet i just started
watching it recently they do like three
episodes a day on comet
that show's amazing star gets a good
show yeah incredible theme
did it change you going through seeing
all these riots this last year
yeah i think it changed my perspective i
mean i don't think it changed me
myself you know like who i am but i
think certainly the way that i view
um not only you know the united states
but also just the way our media
functions
definitely changed my perspectives i'll
i'll ask you more about it after the
intro
for sure thanks richie i am also here in
the corner sorry to cut you off there
ian i'm very excited i always enjoy when
richie has something to add because he
always sees the most
interesting things in the world so i'm
stoked to hear what he's got to say
tonight
before we get started my friends go to
timcast.com become a member and you'll
get access to our exclusive members only
segments which we will have one up
tonight
we do those monday through thursday and
we're also getting ready to launch a new
show in which you will get access to
another members only show that one's
only gonna be about once a week though
but we're gonna keep adding more and
more plus we've got a ton of amazing
journalists who are joining the team
and doing excellent work we're gonna be
hiring a fact checker soon i know i know
we really should have a fact checker
facts checker immediately
but we're hiring literally as fast as we
can and uh with your support as members
we're gonna do more of that stuff more
culture stuff
we just brought on our composer so uh
shout out to carter
who is joining and going to help produce
music
for the crew and for the shows and
everything we do and uh yeah become a
member don't forget to like this video
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends if you really like it
give us all those really good reviews if
you think we're worthy of it
and did i say smash that like button
because i'll say it twice let's get into
that first story
we have an exclusive for timcast.com
from cassandra fairbanks
family of jake gardner files wrongful
death lawsuit against county
special prosecutor and attorney
general's office i just want to read the
opening of this because it's a very
serious and very important story
cassandra writes the parents of a
nebraska bar owner that committed
suicide
after a fatal altercation with violent
rioters have filed a wrongful death
lawsuit against the county
the attorney general two unnamed
detectives and the special prosecutor in
the case
gardner 38 shot and killed a rider who
was attacking him
his elderly father and his business
during last summer's black lives matter
riots
prior to his suicide he was indicted by
a grand jury on counts of manslaughter
use of a firearm in the commission of a
felony
attempted first degree assault and
making terroristic threats
but only after intense political
pressure was placed on the city
the lawsuit accuses the plaintiffs of
conspiring to deprive
gardner of his right to a fair trial and
due process deprivation of sixth
amendment rights
deprivation of 14th amendment rights a
brady rule violation wrongful death
and failing to prevent the deprivation
of his rights gardner was a marine
and veteran of deployments to iraq and
haiti he described himself as a
libertarian but voted for donald trump
in 2016
and volunteered for his campaign in
three states the district attorney had
originally ruled that the shooting was
self-defense on may 30th garner
confronted a group of rioters outside
one of the bars he owned in omaha called
the hive
one of them had just violently attacked
his seventy-year-old father which was
captured on surveillance footage
during the chaos gardner was knocked to
the ground the veteran fired a warning
shot
and attempted to back away the situation
took a tragic turn
after 22 year old rioter james scurlock
jumped on his back and began choking him
the veteran could be heard pleading with
his assailant saying get off me get off
me please get off me
according to the lawsuit the choking
lasted at least 18 seconds
before gardner fatally shot scurlock
skurlock had repeatedly broken windows
at gardner's bar and other businesses in
the area earlier that evening
still the fatal shooting sparked even
more riding in the city which escalated
after donald klein
the douglas county attorney determined
that gardner had acted in self-defense
and declined to bring charges
in what appeared to be a political move
to quell the riots douglas county
district attorney
shelly stretman appointed special
prosecutor frederick d franklin to
handle the case
though the court said that they expected
the same outcome franklin is president
of the midlands bar association
organization
for black only attorneys the lawsuit
notes the special prosecutor had heavily
implied gartner was a racist
when he announced the charges at the
height of the racial tension in the
nation
by saying the decision was not made
because he quote may or may not have
been a racist because
being racist is not against the law
yikes man
there were no hints of racism in the
gardner messages in the in in gardner's
message
or messages or reasons for franklin to
imply that he was
there was the special special prosecutor
inflamed people so much
that gardner received more than 1 600
death threats
that week his family was also forced to
move out of the state for fear their of
their own safety now
the story goes on a bit more there's
there's a statements from the the lawyer
involved
but i want to point out something really
important as we move through the next
you know bit of stories this guy got 1
600 death threats
i'm fairly convinced none of those
people will face any kind of
repercussion for those death threats
but you know for a fact if the person
was in any way anti-establishment
right-wing or populist then that would
have been all over the news as the
extremists are coming et cetera et
cetera
i gotta say this story is
nightmarish it's coming back up because
you know this lawsuit
but here's the guy who begs you know get
off me
had already warned them several times
those warnings terroristic threats
so saith the state the prosecutor
telling someone like back away you know
i'm armed that's making threats now
there's terroristic threats
things look uh i don't know they look
fairly dark i suppose now to be fair
this happened
you know last year and and the lawsuit
is bringing this back up so i don't want
to act like
we're seeing more of this kind of thing
specifically we haven't had the level of
riots we had during the george floyd
riots
but you take a look at the shoving case
which wasn't that long ago
and you get riots and you know the
jurors are scared of retaliation i think
more than one juror said that they were
scared right
do you guys remember i know there was
one alternate i heard though and there
may
i think there's another guy who said
like yeah we yeah there were two of them
yeah
and now we have the the written house
trial coming up
i i am not convinced rittenhouse will
get a fair trial
and a lot of people have said that they
think he will and i'm like
why would why would anybody go up
against this machine where
you can send these people can send all
these death threats and nothing bad
happens to them
that they can go around these people are
literally destroying buildings and
attacking people and they're called the
victims
yeah i don't know i don't know man it's
kind of an example of uh
how like law law is one thing but you
got to kind of put the law aside when
you're looking at what's going on
right now around the world violence is
the last resort
absolute last last desperation resort
you do not do it because if you do it
court of public opinion goes after you
you see sixteen hundred people issued
this guy death threats
sixteen hundred people they were going
to go well he received sixteen hundred
death threats maybe something
as far as he was concerned his life was
over so he took his own life like
that that was without the legal system i
mean obviously the legal system was
busting this guy's balls too
but i mean i i think the common thread
here is that it's the politicization of
our reality and in violent instances is
where it's the most maybe pronounced but
like
i mean just look at obviously all the
all the covid stuff yeah sorry if i'm
quiet there folks i'll
get a little closer here there we go um
with all the kovitz stuff i mean there's
you know it's or if you want to talk
about the quote-unquote lab leak
hypothesis
um that was politicized because you know
trump went one way and everybody else
went the other
and so there was there was that one
doctor who said it that we initially
dismissed this because it was trump who
said am i allowed to say covet on
youtube
yeah yeah oh but be careful because sure
okay if you say if you add the 19
afterwards no i'm kidding
they got weird rules the rules are
absolutely weird yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm
aware of them
for sure the weird thing is like if
biden farted in public and someone
recorded it on their iphone that would
become political
because of why social media and
if biden voided his bowels because of
his old age
they would claim that it's completely
normal uh it's like oh it's not a big
deal it's a normal thing don't worry
about it
do you see the tens of thousands of
views on twitter comments
retweets i gotta be honest probably get
banned they'd say it's it's fake it's
manipulated it's manipulated he didn't
actually avoid his bowels he just took a
dump
i'm wondering like if we need to change
the way our courts work like because
how can we get a fair trial on this day
and age i gotta stress this point man
i think the law is absolutely uh well i
shouldn't say absolutely but
i'm exaggerating but i think the law is
very much so meaningless in a certain in
a certain sense
obviously we follow the laws we
recognize what laws you know
you know what the laws are to the best
of our abilities there's a lot of laws
people don't know about
i was watching this video on never
talking to cops and the guy points out
it's a crime
to accept like see see uh uh
creatures like seafood or creatures or
whatever from someone
if they obtained it uh oh it's like if
it's illegal in another country
to obtain it and they trade it to you
you committed a crime in the u.s like
there are laws that are really
really weird right the problem is though
we can follow the laws to the best of
our abilities we can live peacefully we
say you know violence is wrong
the the issue though is it's cultural if
the law is
don't do x but no one's willing to
prosecute it the law may as well not
exist
right so if the law may as well right
the law
may as well right now be do not you know
vandalism
destruction of private property is a
crime a felony punishable
by up to a year in jail or some class a
misdemeanor
punishable about by up to a year in jail
if your right wing
that's what it should say or it should
say you know uh an exemption is included
for anyone who who toes the
establishment line like the
age-old situation is if you have the mob
the crowd the populace on your side
the court's gonna side with you they're
gonna get you off or they're gonna
prosecute who you want to prosecute and
if you know the
the judge they're going to get you off
sort of i think that i think that's how
it
kind of used to be yeah but knowing the
judge was
connections and access to resources
there's something that
there's there's two motivating factors
here one would be greed
where the judge is like oh that's you
know so-and-so's kid you know if i
could do him a favor the other is fear
oh if i don't prosecute this guy they're
going to show up and burn my house down
whatever they say so now we have to a
two-tiered justicism it's
you can call it a narco tyranny or you
can call it something worse
you've got ideological courts where
they'll be like well they're protesting
arrest the guy give them all the charges
in the book is going to prison
and then when the death threats come in
we don't care
no one's protesting that so long as
regular people
the politically homeless conservatives
whatever don't
protest they've lost they've lost their
their chance in my opinion to be
to be completely honest too there was
maybe a period five six years ago where
the right could have gone out and done
big mass peaceful protests
now you get a handful of guys to walk
out with american flags and they'll
scream the far right's coming the far
right's coming
the media will claim you're a white
supremacist or a nazi and they'll shut
it down in two seconds
how do you fix it you get the jurors all
over the world to port in on like
video chat and listen to the trial and
then vote anonymously
well i mean i think it's the real
problem here is that our court system
everybody's so accessible now so like
everybody's a public figure in some
way you know so if you're if you're a
juror or if you get doxxed
you know basically people can access you
and it's not fun getting
death threats i mean 1500 of them is
that's a lot of 1600 and i mean i've
gotten maybe i don't know a hundred
something like that
but like none of those none of those get
taken seriously they don't go after any
of those people
if they makes you feel unsafe for sure
just you know
tangentially like you know there's a
digital world and there's a real world
but you think about the crossover
and like you know i guess i guess the
problem is if they started prosecuting
stuff immediately
it maybe never would have gotten this
far in the first place like they they
are
letting it get worse and worse until i
think there's going to be a snap
like when regular people don't feel safe
anymore and they just lose their mind
you know what i mean it's like it's
almost like enduring some kind of
torture
where every day you you're inundated
with these stories about violence
against regular people about how the
the justice system is against you and
then you just you don't feel safe right
so there was this um this report a while
ago i was talking about the
arab spring and i might be getting this
wrong but i believe that they basically
said like
there's there's a uh three things that
people need
and it's food shelter and security they
need to know
the security is there is their knowledge
that they can exist they can survive
they'll be able to you know live they
need a place to live
and they need to eat food and if you
take one of those things away
in large enough numbers you'll get a
revolution so
security is extremely important the idea
that people feel safe and secure and can
trust
that they won't be gulagged i suppose
but that's going away it's it's going
away when you get when you get to
stories like this
and you get everything we've seen now i
think the written house thing is going
to be
really serious uh because i you know you
know you don't got to say anything i'll
say it
i'll actually i'll i'll quote destiny
you know destiny was he's a leftist we
had him on the show
and he said it was the clearest case
clearest cut case of self-defense he had
ever seen
kyle rittenhouse and what happened now i
obviously can't say anything
on that because right but playing the
role of witness makes you acutely aware
i mean because you you that's a role
your role is to say what you saw
and not inject you know any opinion on
that
and just like based on the media
coverage that happened after kenosha
i was i was viewed one way or another by
this group or that and by the way i'm no
friend of either side because i'm
also a victim in that case well let's
let's
let's talk about january 6 you can talk
yeah
so but so we can't talk about uh can we
can say why you can't talk about
written house right i'm yeah i mean it's
a pending case and uh
you're a witness i'm a witness right so
we can get to the point of this by
talking about something else
january 6 where the new york times
they called you a writer they did in
print they printed it
oh wait there was a correction that was
like a number of pages later but
you open up the new york times magazine
and i can just imagine frame it my
friend's parents at home just
oh it's a nice sunday hoping richie oh
oh my god i mean actually you know what
i'll take a death threat over
i got called uh yashar ali posted a
thread
of photos of what that guy and i'm not
going to name the photographer
you know who you are you know what you
saw
and you saw me looking for my phone and
that caption still went in there calling
me a rioter
who punched a door and they issued two
corrections
and this is still outstanding new york
times you should still be scared
because what happened there was i
because
um of the way that i looked and because
i just been pepper sprayed
and because i had like you know wet hair
and i was
i looked desperate and i was they
labeled me as something and that image
that image and and i got called a meth
head like 200 times and
um i don't know you you have press
credentials
yeah you got snatch for me that day
you're officially reporting and your
phone falls
i have congressional press credentials
right i can go in there
on any given day and your phone falls
and it's behind the door
well i thought it was behind the door so
i was tapping on the window to ask the
police it turned out the guy
and that's the that's the most
objectionable part of this whole
situation is that
there was another woman who was
photographed two minutes later and it's
actually time coded in the piece as two
minutes later from my photo
and she's got a maga hat on and she's
crying and it says a woman was pepper
sprayed they called me a writer cause
i'm oh
knuckle dragon trump's our border i look
like that and by the way
didn't vote for trump um but i looked to
be that way
they didn't they didn't do any research
and by the way they relied on my
reporting
after what happened in kenosha well
that's what they should have known you
know
let's say they didn't that you don't
look like a trump supporter
you look like a young white man which i
look like a neanderthal they could frame
it
like you or some you know that's the
narrative and i look angry and there's a
broken window
and even though i was tapping on it with
one finger saying please officers
can you look for my phone at your feet
and they were all obliging by the way
and they were looking down
and they were i was like yeah right
there is it is it down there
tapping oh i punched the door so this
this photojournalist
they're the one who lied i don't know i
don't know what the editorial process
was
i don't know who it was that wrote the
caption because in some news outlets
you know sometimes the editors write the
captions they edit the captions
but there's a way to find out there is a
way to find out and
i can go that route i just have to wait
for my dogecoin to go a little higher
and it's bumping so there's one of two
scenarios here this is really important
to the conversation
either the photojournalist on scene who
saw what happened
lied because he wanted that juicy photo
look what i got oh i got that guy at the
window
even though they knew it's not what
happened he lied or maybe he didn't
maybe the editor said hey looks like a
writer i'll write that down and did not
fact check yeah if but here's the thing
is i don't know when the photographer
found out what that caption was
but my point is is that he was there two
minutes later when that woman was
photographed and i was gone from that
space
and here's what happened right after i
tapped on the window every cop was
looking down
there were like 10 cops on the other
side of that door and i looked so
desperate that they actually obliged and
then this guy tapped me on the shoulder
said yo man i got kicked back here
i hugged him i said thank you so much to
to all the cops i went down the line and
then i said thank you to everybody i
said please everybody be safe
i'm out of here i'm done for the day and
i'm not kidding people were clapping
they were like oh this guy found his
phone like he looked so desperate and
sad and now he found it
and i i hugged the guy i said can i hug
you and he said yeah
and so it was a scene it was a true like
anybody who was there saw it
and so i don't know if he was looking
down at his frickin camera or whatever
he was doing
but i want to find out media
organizations are putting out
fake news making it impossible for us to
know what is really going on
and so i was having i had a really long
conversation lawsuits are for
yeah but who can afford a hundred grand
and then the new york times
puts a bunch of their high-powered
multi-million dollar lawyers on it and
get it crushed and say oh
it was an opinion doge is bumping right
now no he's just bumping i guess
i was talking to a friend man it's not a
hundred grand but it it can get there
very quickly
it's crazy how many people there are
that
don't know what is going on in any
capacity because they only absorb news
passively
so they turn on they were the new york
times yeah like my friends parents
and they and they said i look like a
terrorist and i can never you know
and that's like you know what my dad
taught me to to stand tall
and that's what i'm gonna have to do
here because i'm not gonna let those
guys stomp on me
because they think i look somewhere you
look at the store the segment we were
just talking about before this one the
the gardener you know jay gardner he
took his own life the mob was coming
after him
you see what happens when the media
falsely frames things it makes them
money
to get the mob all angry and you know
what man they don't care they don't care
that they burn the system down i i
genuinely believe
i had a long conversation with peter
pagosian james lindsey
mostly peter bergochen uh they're the
guys from the there's and helen pluck
rose they were
the crew that did the square hoax but i
was mostly talking to peter pagosan
about how i think the media is the
problem
and he said he thought it was the
universities talking about critical race
theory wokeness the conflict and
everything and i was like
it it is i'm not saying it's not i know
critical race theory came out of
universities
but it only found its path to the
mainstream because of
social media algorithms and media
manipulation then you look at the
the curve of all all of a sudden you see
all these buzz words appearing
lexus lexisnexis data showing like
around 2010
the instances of the word racism
skyrocket
like a thousand percent ten thousand
percent
this is what opens that opens the door
for all of this woke stuff from these
universities
but i i will also concede as well that
you had a lot of young people in
universities
now entering the workforce at a similar
time being indoctrinated
by these ideas but i genuinely believe
the door was open because
manipulat social media news companies
there was this
this nexus event where social media was
destroying news companies
venture capitalist funded firms jumped
in with no
with no care in the world for fact
checking or any credibility and start
pumping out rage bait garbage on
facebook
drives everybody insane now now what's
happened is you can see this
the new york times quickly realized in
the mid 2010s
we can't compete with buzzfeed buzzfeed
can just say some crazy garbage
and get a million clicks we got to play
that game too
so the new york times gets on new york
times gets on board we see this when
like that
that opinion editor guy he was forced to
resign because he published
an op-ed from tom cotton which was like
standard procedure but they're like
we're going to do the insurrection act
right yeah and they're like
we're going to do whatever the audience
wants to make money and we're going to
we're going to pander
they hired that that one woman sarah
jong who was posting unrepented racist
things on twitter for years but you know
what i don't you don't you think that
we're
now in a diversion society where you
know like
the twitterati and corporate media are
going in one direction and normal common
sense people are going in another
and i just will say like the one thing
i'll say about kenosha and i think that
this is actually like a silver
lining of kind of the
obstacle course that i had to navigate
in terms of dealing with the media after
what happened just trying to say what i
saw
so what happened was i went on tucker
because he asked me on first he was only
you know right after the shooting he
said you know you want to see what
happened and
so i explained on that show
live to his whole audience what i what
he told
me he was there for kyle rittenhouse why
he was there what he said
okay what he told me cnn then took that
in a report
and i won't name the reporter but he
said
mcginnis supported the conservative
claim that rittenhouse
acted in self-defense and so then i
emailed cnn legal and i said um
you made a misstatement about me i
relayed what the motivation of the
shooter was
which he told me 15 minutes before this
you were reporting yes
exactly and so you can do one of two
things and this is america
and when you want to get something done
you just threaten to sue people
that's right and i said you can have me
on to correct the record or prepare for
court and guess what
that reporter uh i give him a lot of
credit he had me he had me back on
probably because the cnn guys went
to the legal department said you better
fix this or we're gonna you know and
that was six minutes long that they did
and you know what they did a very good
job of covering the event
after that fact so well good for them uh
i worked for fusion
which was the abc news univision joint
venture i was in san jose
and i was at this trump event there was
a massive crowd running around beating
people it was it was insane they were
many of them were bernie supporters i
know because some of them were carrying
you know bernie swag and said they were
and
uh incidentally that's incidental this
guy comes out
and he's you know cheering he's like
yeah trump and they're all screaming at
him spitting on him and he keeps walking
he turns the corner someone runs up with
a heavy bag and smacks him in the head
with it
he starts bleeding and i'm fil i run up
i'm filming the whole thing i he he
starts crossing the street the police
has quartered my chase chase him up
chase chase him down you know i'm
running after him i'm like hey can i can
you tell me what happened i'm filming
so i get this very short clip where he's
like i'm just walking and someone hits
me
the video gets like a million views in
less than a day i we
the pr team i believe it was pr at uh
fusion
immediately got hit up by fox news can
your can we have your reporter come on
and tell us what happened the the higher
ups message me like hey do you want to
go
like we do pr do you want to go on
kavuto and i was like what's that like
fox news and i was like
should i i'm like it's fox news like and
they're like yeah yeah i should totally
do it and i was like
okay so i i'd go on fox news and talk
about what happened i'm like yeah he hit
with the bag
we don't know what it was and then
people at the company
after seeing that i went to fox news
called me a white supremacist
i'm like but they told me to do it see
the people who are running the company
didn't know
what they were really supporting when
they hired young psychotic
woke cult members they were just like
it's young activists
so when in their gen x or minds they
were like doing pr is normal we don't
care if he goes on fox news
but they didn't realize that that that
the the tribalism
of the younger millennials and the older
gen z was if you dare go on and talk to
any of these people
you are them or worse it's an
interesting phenomenon don't you think
there's a flip side too though where
there's like
if you're on cnn you're a communist or
you're not msn absolutely not
no absolutely not politics only flows in
one direction
if a right-wing person goes and meets
with the left-wing person
they call the left-wing person
right-wing
there's there's no like a left-wing
person can go to a maga event and
they're like he's actually right-wing
a right-wing person can go to a
left-wing event like the event was
actually right-wing
we put on an event called ending
violence it was a
meeting of the minds or whatever ending
violence racism and authoritarianism
and we had daryl davis the famed like
uh activist who got 200 plus klansmen to
quit the clan he was our headline
speaker
and they claimed because we had some
right-wing people it was a far-right
event of racists
so even if you have you know daryl davis
and prominent
we had we had leftists we had social
justice activists they showed up the
whole event was far right they
threatened to burn down the theater the
theater canceled on us
we had to move it to a casino in order
in order to hold it and we ended up
losing half our capacity
and we sold we had sold out so we had
lost a ton and
what do you do you threaten to sue well
i think that's the point is
you have to attack the gatekeepers right
and the gatekeepers of you know the way
that people especially after all the
lockdowns the way that people interpret
reality
is through the media and so if
if something is being interpreted
something that's happening in reality is
being interpreted incorrectly you go to
this you go to the people who
who put that forth so you call me this
you call me a rioter
how did that happen i got two
corrections out of the new york times it
wasn't enough because they
they still printed right the fact that i
was a writer and put corrections behind
it want to know why
because it's more expensive to reprint
right
and my reputation was worth i don't know
what was it worth i'm
i darn well would like to find out
because that was the sole reason why
they didn't reprint the actual caption
i don't know what i'm going to do but
i'm going to get to the bottom of it
i think you should talk to veritas no i
don't think i should at all
because they're partisan actors in my
mind all right and i want to approach
this from
the direction of truth and not from some
kind of ideological
side and i'm not like oh take down the
new york slimes because
they're all commies or whatever i i i
think well they don't
veritas wouldn't say that no but i
understand that they're viewers i'm
being hyperbolic but yeah
i i you know they're viewed as a certain
thing right um
by you know the greater media and i'd
rather come at it as just an individual
who's trying to stand tall for myself
and
um you guys know what if whatever maybe
maybe
i'm a young young enough to enter
financial ruin for my you know for the
sake of
the truth i gotta manage i think i'll
settle with you
well i don't care i want what i want
them to know is that i'm willing to go
the distance
in order to get to the bottom of what
happened and so if they want to settle
to just
set that aside i don't know if i'm
interested in that there's an
interesting tweet that i saw from
jack posobik i saw it from lucret casca
i saw it from mike cernovich
the ten stages of genocide have you seen
this this graphic
middle have you seen it all right so
said assess and it's a graphic that has
ten steps it says the ten stages of
genocide let me read them
number one classification people are
divided into us and them number two
symbolization people are forced to
identify themselves
number three discrimination people begin
to face systematic discrimination
four dehumanization people equate with
animals vermin or diseases
five organization the government creates
specific groups to enforce the policies
six polarization the government
broadcasts propaganda to turn the
populace against the group
seven preparation official action to
remove and relocate people
eight is persecution the beginning of
murders theft of property
trial massacres nine is extermination
wholesale elimination of the group
it is not extermination and on uh uh
it is extermination and not murder
because people are not considered human
and ten is denial the government denies
it has committed any crime
so mike cernovich shared this many
people are sharing it and they're asking
where you think we are
mike cernovich's post said 6.5 just
before
seven that we are just about to see
official action to remove and relocate
people
i saw many people responding to the
memes saying they think we're at between
six or seven
i'm not entirely sure i'm convinced i
think people might be
really hyping things up like i i
understand there's
like the a lopsided justice system right
now
i understand there's problems but to say
we're just about to see official action
to remove a group of people
i think that's going a little bit too
far from a lot of these personalities i
mean what do you guys think
uh three somewhere between three and six
uh we didn't form an
uh an organization to take care of
capital police well that was already
formed they're expanding it
into their they're becoming a new
intelligence agency and they're going
nationwide right
that's why i said between because it's
not officially a new organization
to do that as well that's semantics bro
come on the current organization that's
semantics like they didn't build the
republican extermination fund or
anything do you know what the secret
service is tasked with doing
i have no idea tracking counterfeit us
dollars
did you know that no what did you think
they did guarded the presidency that's
right
because that was that was dude the
department of energy the department of
energy is like the biggest weapons
program
that's where i learned that fact about
the secret service yeah they did it was
counterfeiting
and so so of course of course
i say that's that's that's a semantic
argument the the argument put forth by
mike
which was the capital police are
becoming a local police a federal police
agency just for the for this for the dc
but now they're going to operate in
california florida look man
you you see these things and i talked
about this in chicago they'll knock the
whole building down except for just the
facade
and claim it's the same building but
everybody knows it's not the same
building
the law is so long as one wall stands it
legally is
so the floors are different the size is
different and it's like a weird-looking
building with this tiny like two-story
front brick frame
and there's a steel building behind it
or something ridiculous so anyway
but but i i don't completely disagree
with you in you know it's a broad it's a
broad stretch to say between three and
six
so the first thing i'll point out is
classification obviously we're all
divided between us and them in a lot of
different ways
the left the right the far right
whatever
who's being forced to identify
themselves is anybody forced to do
anything
i'm not that worried i mean this is
america i think we'll figure it out
they've got the pronouns in the twitter
bio but it's not
for some organizations might fire you if
you don't identify your well that's
still that i think that's more the
question here is like it's not your
actual physical well-being more so as
it's like
your ability to operate in polite
society right as
you know somebody who's like you know if
you lose paypal if you lose any access
to
banks and stuff like that i mean and
that's i mean you heard about what's
going on right
uh there was an announcement from paypal
working with the adl to
to weed out extremist transactions and
then facebook youtube and twitter
announced
that they're going to be targeting uh
what are they they say attacker
manifestos in the f in the far right
including the proud boys content so
proud boys content is now like to be
purged
so they're not just talking about
censorship now they're talking about
financial restrictions
and censorship and they're playing this
game of the far right
so all that needs to happen is a sustain
a long enough campaign where enough
media outlets call you far right and
then they can say oh but look it's it's
here he's far right everyone knows it
someone uh i think it was a democratic
politician
tweeted out that their people were
vermin did you guys see that last week
brother they say maggots
yeah maggots and vermin that's the
dehumanization and then the
extermination
it's not murder if they're rats you know
that's what's maggots but don't you
think anything
so like i mean i've had both experiences
which is i've had reporters
reach out to me about kenosha for
example and get
totally like talk to him for hours and
have them totally manipulate what i said
you know for their own agenda but then
i've also had you know situations where
like
huffington post and um a new yorker
article that just came
article that just came out by paige
williams i talked to her at length
and she didn't put that qualifier
right-wing daily caller in there
and i talked to her afterwards and she
said yeah because you know i talk to you
and you know you well they're they're
real journalists yeah so they're i mean
my point is is that
it's not like this monolith of just bad
people
in the corporate media i think if you
really make an effort to actually
extend your hand and and try to tell
your truth to those people rather than
just shutting yourself down and saying
no no no you had this agenda and i'm not
going to talk to you
sure you might fall on your face a
couple times and the intercept might put
a hit piece out on you
um this is funny
at least you're trying and i think it
some good comes to that the splc hit me
up
and asked for a statement and so i wrote
like a really long statement
and i was like i genuinely think that
jack dorsey's
stated intention is to have basically
everyone be on these platforms even
people we all kind of disagree shouldn't
we all kind of agree shouldn't be like
there's there's
there are free speed free speech
absolutists but you know there's like
certain things you shouldn't be posting
on social media like images of you know
i'll just i'll leave it at that
and i was like jack dorsey told me that
his goal is immutable
social media that he wants to make
blockchain social medias nothing can
ever be taken down and i'm like
bro that's that's way over the top like
i'm not asking for that
i'm just like let people have political
opinions you don't ban him for saying
learn to code
he's like not everything no i don't
believe him or
he doesn't have the power that he that
people think he has on twitter but so
this guy asks me and i basically you
know gave him a full honest opinion and
he calls me a far-right reactionary
i'm like bro if you actually and so what
he did was
there's a clever thing that i think he
did to avoid looking like he's lying
he put my statement as an external link
instead of including it in the piece
because then when you go to it you're
like oh this guy's kind of moderate you
know what i mean like he's not really
far left or anything but
i think you tapped on a really important
point right there though and that goes
back to what we were saying about
you know are we at the point where you
know people are being identified as
groups and you know removed like
physically
no but um and i like coach uh
some like 20 somethings you know zoomers
in hockey and
one thing i noticed is the degree to
which you can say whatever you want to
them in person you can throw whatever
words about you want and they won't
really be phased but if somebody says
something about them digitally
it's like it consumes them you know even
if it's just in a snapchat even if it's
an
instagram comments or whatever because
that lives forever
and so like if you google whoever's name
and this news outlet decides to say this
that's immutable
and until you know something else
becomes the top result that's you
yeah that's a big problem with the
because what i've
been looking to say culture uh politics
is downstream of culture
big popular i think it was breitbart
then i realized that well
uh culture is downstream of technology
so these technological algorithms that
are supporting
you know rage trash bait like they say
ian cross owns a psychopath and then
that gets retweeted so then that in
fortifies the algorithm and then all of
a sudden and e and crossland start
showing up that's why this digital
statement is so much more powerful than
a verbal statement because it's feeding
the technological
problem there a good example is uh
some smear some gizmodo article this is
really funny the left has like one video
clip of me they love to regurgitate
because like the only real thing i guess
they have
and it's from like a year and a half ago
and so gizmodo wrote it up
like a few months ago and in this
article
where they take this clip you know out
of context they claim tim poole's
mostly right-wing audience and then i'm
like
what what does that mean like did you
pull them
do you know who the audience is and then
what happened was a couple other outlets
regurgitated the article and said the
same thing exactly and then someone put
it on my wikipedia
tim poole's audience is mostly
right-wing well like i guess you know
i don't i don't know if it's still there
or not but in the talk second section
you can see them saying like
something about just because someone
says it an article doesn't mean it's
true
and they're like well then a couple like
three three articles have all claimed it
so we don't we we're not the ones to
investigate if they say it's true then
we include it
and i'm like yo none of these people
have actually asked my audience who they
are what they believe
and the and the trump supporters like
the the the diehard troopers really
don't like me
over like my reaction to joe biden
winning the election it's like
you know we did a poll and found i think
the biggest group was libertarian
the the the plurality was libertarian
and then
like um trump supporters uh moderates
and then liberals and there are even
some progressives about kanye west
voters
oh that's like 70 like just everybody no
no but the point is
like what does it mean to be a right
wing are libertarians
necessarily right wing not necessarily i
mean what happened to the left
libertarians of which made up most of
the young people in like the early 2010s
who are now the anti-sjw types certainly
shifting i mean i think we're in the
midst of a shift so
obviously it's kind of up in the air
right now and it's a question of where
the where the chips will fall
but what does left and right even mean
nothing man nothing it it
so so here's the problem you go to
somebody and you
and you know we had steve bannon here
steve bannon said he was far right
and i was like steve you just attacked
the rich and he was like well i'm a
populist and i'm like how is that [ __ ]
up
i've always been opposed to that kind of
you know characterization i mean we have
in america because of the two-party
system we have a very binary way of
like viewing our reality and it's like
you know i growing up i don't think it
was that much of an issue
like it was never like oh you you know
are you a republican or a democrat
and now it's like where do you fall i
think
jimmy what do you think of donald trump
well if if you if you like him do you
like him how much do you like him
he's a funny guy make america great
again
do you vow january 6th a vow
say it right now disavow i i i disavow
that's my point though is everything you
know the weirdest thing about online
arguments is
it's like some leftists will come up and
they'll be like well
will you you complain about black lives
matter this about january 6 and i'll go
i just about january because it's really
bad and they're like well
and it's really funny right now because
a lot of conservatives are saying my
body my choice
over you know vaccine stuff and the left
is like the pro-lifers have no idea what
you're talking about and i'm like i've
always been pro-choice and i think my
body my choice pertains to all of it
yeah they don't argue with me about it
because they're like what do we say
about that guy
oh he's consistent in his positioning
i'm like dude
it's because they don't understand what
libertarian is
right i'm not gonna pretend to be like
big l libertarian in any way
i'm just kind of like i don't know and
you kind of should leave people alone i
guess
but you're right i mean it's a question
of like cultural conservatism
versus like i would argue that you know
trumpian conservatism
has less of that cultural aspect of
conservatism i don't think you know
like do we all can we honestly say like
what 20 years ago was trump like
anti-abortion
nope not a democrat not at all yeah
exactly doing cocaine off of hookers
here's
the dude's not conservative he's
populist and so he got a lot of new
people into the republican party
but i want to go back to that splc
things i mentioned this before i
mentioned this the other day
when they refer to me as a reactionary
and then show
my full statement where i'm like i said
you know i said bigots have no place in
polite society like bigots
homophobes transphobes racist have no
place in polite society
he includes that and says that's
reactionary it's like okay what you're
really saying is that you're an
insurrectionist
the southern poverty law center these
organizations and these activists
are insurrectionists who want a complete
upheaval and overthrow of the us
government
because reactionary are the people who
oppose the revolution so
you can have leftist values you can
believe in the progressive social
justice cause
but if you tell them they're wrong for
wanting to burn everything to the ground
they'll call you a reactionary
i literally come out like several times
a month talking with people about
healthcare and i'm like i think we need
universal healthcare
like a basic level maybe i've leaned
away from it a little bit because of the
race-based vaccine rollouts and my
concern is that if we have
government-based healthcare
and then the the racists take over
they'll make everything race-based and
then
withhold healthcare from people based on
that's scary but that's not left-wing
i can say tax the rich not left-wing
what is it
do you support the upheaval and
overthrow of american culture
or don't you because if you if you like
apple pie and baseball or whatever
you're a reactionary you can believe in
all the good social justice stuff
you can make a documentary about
blockbusting and redlining and racism
doesn't matter will you support the
revolution yes or no
but don't you think to a certain extent
the quote-unquote
cultural revolution that you're
referring to is mainstream now like
don't you
think that the critique is now the
mainstream insofar
as like the majority of people think
that about apple pie and baseball that
like you know
america is corrupt and america is doomed
to be racist and terrible forever
i look at the polling and i think it's
fair to say that the ultra woke make up
a tiny percentage relatively but it's
growing i think
in our media i think it's a different
story in the media it's like about 80
percent the algorithm is it's coffee so
i'm not talking about like average
everyday americans because traveling
around the country
right that's not the case but i'm not so
convinced
because it's not necessarily so look i
had it i i talked to
i'm talking to my friend and we're
arguing about
you know like uh vaccine passports and
requirements stuff like that i'll be
light on the crux of the conversation
because youtube is ban happy but
suffice it to say i said i don't trust
the government
blindly you know i'll consider what they
say and consider the source you always
consider the source
i don't trust big pharma i don't and i
don't understand why the left has come
out in favor of a massive for-profit
venture
to transfer tax funds to major
pharmaceuticals yes
instead of talking about real ways to
help save lives through the health care
system
that being said i think vaccines are
safe and effective i absolutely do
i and i have one thing i've absolutely
stressed is that we've had like 360
million doses of the vaccine
theirs is serious one of the like the
very reporting is serious one of the
problems is that
when you censor the conversation you you
freak people out
so this guy is is coming at me arguing
that's by simply telling people
to go talk to their own doctor about
what's right for them and make sure the
doctor
because i genuinely believe it's the
right thing to do because people could
have allergies or whatever
he's like well you're scaring people and
i'm like dude when did you become the
champion of big pharma what
yeah it's about the collective and not
your individual decision and that's the
point the benefit of the collective over
the individual and the primacy of the
individual is the foundation
you know the fact that every individual
is inherited in the image of god that's
that's america right there exactly my
point so to go back to what we're
talking about before i got into that
that was the idea that there could be
something so
uh innately leftist stop giving taxpayer
funds to
for-profit pharmaceutical companies and
they actively
defend it right now because it's for
it's for their their their collective
has formed a narrative that must be
upheld at all costs that's why we're in
a paradigm shift right now
because the the progressives are the
corporatists now right right it's like
my mom
in the early you know late 60s early 70s
in washington dc
she was a progressive who was fighting
again and i had this conversation with
her the other day and i was just like
yo mom like what's the you know what do
you think about like
you know these modern feminists these
modern and she's like it's you know
i can't say what she said because she's
um
because she's not family friendly you
know and that's exactly what we're going
going back to what we were saying
earlier is the critique has become the
mainstream
and so it's no longer revolutionary and
it's become
stale and guess what corporatized i
don't think it's like a corporate
message
now wait wait wait you mean you mean the
activists
yes mainstream exactly so i'm saying i
thought you were saying criticizing the
woke was mainstream
no no well not yet but i think that you
know
we're in the midst of a shift right now
but all i'm saying is that when my mom
was protesting
in washington dc protesting the vietnam
war
that was very different from you know um
i think
that was a fringe portion of the society
it was the young people who thought one
way and that now the corporations think
just like
those people who are on the streets
that's all i'm saying this is the fourth
turning
you're familiar with the fourth training
right fourth turning no no
no no so you know it's it's the this the
four seasons every 80 years there's
yes okay yeah every 20 years you have a
cycle yeah all right so if those aren't
familiar
there's a historian how generational
theory yeah and so
you've got these the the different
seasons within it there's four periods
they're about 20
20 years long each this is what's what
we're seeing right now
with uh this what you referred to as the
paradigm shift right
like your mom was counter culture
opposing the major corporations
now that the the generation today the
young generation is pro corporate
amazon's got their black lives matter
log you know netflix all these big
there's a video game i can't remember
what video game it was it opened up and
it said black lives matter
the the attacking the establishment has
become the establishment in a very
weird way but this is why i say it's the
fourth turning
when you had a youth you had a culture
of young people growing up
being told to fight the power you know
fight the system fight the man
then when they all become adults and
inherit the power their worldview is
still fight the power
so now they're in power yeah telling
everyone to fight the power
which leads us to the fourth season the
fourth turning the great conflict is
if you take an entire generation and
tell them the system is broken and
corrupt and you must fight back
they inherit the power and then start
ripping it to shreds and gutting it
yeah you're going to get a crisis
imagine you're you're fl you're driving
in a car
and some dudes actively like punching
holes in the floor and trying to
you know jam things against your drive
shaft or something you're going to crash
but i think if we live in a flourishing
fully functioning society
then we actually raise people who are
critical thinkers
who are able to you know shed their old
self and see
uh you know a new truth or or change
their perspective as they get older
and like just like my mom did and you
know sure and now what did she really
well i think she did you know i think
she had a certain way of viewing
politics
um in the last five years that she's
certainly changed i mean maybe as a
byproduct of like
being you know me being her son my
younger brother like caught her on like
a work zoom meeting like
yeah so everybody knows that uh you know
it's
so it's all just media narratives and
he's like
you can't come on like this is not for
zoom
it is it is though my son told me this
so it really is it's like you know uh
hard times make strong men strong strong
men make good times good times weak men
weak men hard times et cetera et cetera
because you have this period of like you
know look the boomers man were they they
were like hippies and protesters and
now they're all leading these big
corporations and what happened you know
what i mean
how have you seen slc punk that movie
have you seen slc punkin no oh come on
you guys what's it about
it's about this guy in salt lake city
he's a punk and then it ends with him
like wearing a suit and
okay like at a certain point people
accept the establishment
and you know it's it's really
interesting to see how generations play
a role in this
the children of the boomers the echo
boomers or the millennials i like that
word echo boomer people
people don't call millennials echo
boomers though uh they inherited
a lot of the anger and rage of the fight
the man eff the system from their boomer
parents
so they grow up with that instilled
completely in them
and then when they inherit the system
the moment they do
they start doing all sorts of wacky
broken fwbs yeah but so
here's my question is if everything that
you're saying about
like why why is fighting the system now
supporting joe biden like where did burn
you know where did bernie go
yeah that's a great question so that's
bernie journey bernie
here's how did that like revolutionary
movement get completely hijacked and now
like the wall is over
everybody's eyes or are people actually
awake to this and it's just
our media is far removed from the way
that you know everyone's like dude
collectivism they they're i don't know i
don't know
it's a weird comp it's i think it's an
amalgam of
the the generation assumes the power and
becomes
the the establishment while telling
everyone to fight the establishment not
realizing it's them
and so then they target the not
establishment like
republicans have states that's what they
have they control what is it 36 states
or something like that
that's not the the power paradigm to a
certain extent i mean it's powerful
having that many sense if they get i
think two more states or whatever then
they can have a constitutional
convention
but for the for the most part in this
country universities movies video games
federal level politics social media too
social media it's all left it's all
progressive
and that's what that's what ultimately
compels people to
make decisions in their reality like
government is one thing
and you make a very concerted you know
decision very like
you go to the polls to vote for this
person because i ideologically think
this but in terms of like
i have a friend who i'm not going to
name similarly to why you wouldn't but
he has a wedding of his his actually his
best
best friend's brother in canada right
and it's coming up
and it's like should i get vaccinated
just to go to the wedding because
my buddy's gonna be sad if i don't and
everybody at that wedding is gonna say
where is he
you know oh he's he's not here because
he doesn't have the facts and he
couldn't get over the border
social press and so then it's social
it's social pressure that's
compelling you to make a medical
decision and that's that's the problem i
have with it
you know and that specific subject like
you got to talk to your doctor man like
this this the i he did and
and yeah it's it's doctor well i'm not
going to say what has happened
he made his decision and and that but
that's what i told him all his friends
were saying something different
did he end up going um i
think what's going to happen and i don't
want to say too much because i'm not
sure
he's going to try to go without the you
know situation
[Laughter]
and see what happens your doctor might
trouble you man like yeah
like look you you talk to a doctor and
they might actually tell you you might
be surprised
i can't believe there's so many people
who who don't trust their doctors to be
completely honest
exactly well here's the amount of people
that are telling that individual
yo like i can't believe that you would
do that you know because it's a medical
personal medical decision that he's
making
and it's becoming this like you're a bad
person because you think
because you're doing that yeah when they
talk about it's like the collective oh
what about everybody else
with this genocide thing splitting
people into groups i was thinking about
the vaxxed and the non-vaxxed
as opposed to the pronouns yes
and the it's not just maggots and like
you know liberals or whatever like did
you get the vaccine
yeah what vaccinations well but for what
there's so much general turmoil so
tongue-in-cheek
there's a funny cross over there between
like the granola major lefties who
are anti-vaxxed for a certain reason
right right
yeah exactly and so like it's a weird
like you know the marianne williamson
supporters
oh people who wanna live naturally and
then the people that actually are afraid
of the vaccine are completely
different different things were lefties
left libertarians man this is what i
can't stand when i go on political
compass memes on reddit
you ever see it's a great subreddit by
the way it's really funny political
compass memes because
they they wreck every reg on everybody
but they keep claiming the libertarian
left as antifa and woke and i'm like
that's
not what the libertarian left is the
woke antifa left
are authoritarians who want to beat
people i mean there was a video
that was posted by ford fisher where
there were guys outside
of like a medical it was like a medical
facility and they were anti-mask they
were like don't wear masks and antifa
showed up and started beating them for
not following state
guidelines that is not left libertarian
left libertarians are like
marion williamson they insult her they
called her the woo-woo
crystal lady and she was like i don't
have crystals
but you wanna you wanna know what left
libertarian is it is
the hippies who are like i eat tree bark
because it cured my
my skin rash or whatever like they're
the hippies the weirdo the crystal
wearings
and and look you know luke we we love
luke we love but he wears crystals too
and he's
like your bones are made of crystal
hydroxy appetite
your bones are made of graphene
the point is the point is left
libertarians are
these people and and the reason why
they're adamantly opposed
is for personal decision reasons for the
most part
but they get mocked as kooky and crazy
and what's funny is whenever i bring up
to i was like i was talking a lefty
friend of mine about lefty conspiracies
and of course i mentioned russia gate
and ukraine getting all the stuff and
they're like well i don't know man well
we'll see
that's that that's still out you know
we'll see where that wait wait
for the mueller report to drop yeah
that's right no but they they think that
like
mueller will be revealed and i'm like
bro this is blue and non-level stuff
and then when i mention the lefty
anti-vex people which were like the
the preeminent anti-vaxxers to begin
with they're like that's not true
those people aren't left-wing and i'm
like have you talked to them
yeah they are like as lefty commune
hippie flower wearing as you can get
yeah i mean it's the same thing as the
you know basically
like this weird progressive support for
the police state
and the intelligence state and it's like
yo i was
like i grew up anti-bush anti-iraq war
and as a result like anti-patriot act
and like
if like i were a true lefty i'd be
supporting like the cia
right now like what we we just watched
south
south land tales you ever see it no
it was made in what year was it 2007 i
don't know
it's i think 2007 maybe 2006 and it was
made by the guy who did donnie darko and
it's it's like
man you you guys gotta check this movie
out because it was written
about a future not too distant future
where
like a nuclear war happens and then
you've got the republicans who expand
the patriot act and the democrats who
have like
there's like the rise of the neo-marxist
movement it's just really fascinating to
watch a movie from the mid-2000s
to see where the liberals thought our
society would go
because were they wrong they were like
the republicans were going to become
you know authoritarian expanding the
patriarch all that stuff
and instead what do we get we got the
the the the reality tv star real estate
guy
who calls him horse face on twitter like
certainly not the same he won't even
call in the the police
to deal he won't call in federal uh uh
the insurrection act to deal with riots
in that movie
they actually had like special forces
that were just shooting marxists
like that's what these people thought
was gonna happen back then
didn't happen so i gotta ask in this
movie was a republican the president or
was the democrat the president because
obama
was elected and then everyone was like
oh my gosh this is such a great thing
i can't remember um i you know i'm not a
big fan of the movie to be a play honest
i was like kind of half watching it
but it very much so like it's got a ton
of people like sarah michelle gellars in
it justin timberlakes in it the rocks in
it
weird yeah yeah yeah sean william scott
is that his name he's in it yeah
idiocracy is definitely more more
prophetic than uh
definitely yeah idiocracy for sure you
know it's actually a great book that um
is actually the last book that my dad
ever gave me before he passed yeah
sorry but it's significant in that
respect because it's called arrogance
and it's um it's bernard goldberg and
it's it's the sequel to bias but
basically
the sub head for that book is rescuing
rescuing america from the media elite
and in that book what he predicts is you
know at that time in 2003 i think it was
written
the nightly news was getting like 25
million
views per broadcast and he's like that
is all going to
crumble and as it crumbles they'll be
trying to cling
to control of the narrative and i mean
that's really what we're witnessing i
mean papers and you know the nightly
news cable news is it's all
collapsing and they have to just you
know ratings
i mentioned this six years ago because
uh the ceo of i said there was gonna be
a bloodbath
in digital he was like it's not gonna
last and the reason for it
in my opinion was that a lot of these
digital news outlets were doing this
this trick
called it was it was called like um ads
ad rights uh
yeah ad rights assignments something
like that here's what they would do
they would you'd make a website and
we'll call it like superawesomenews.com
or whatever well i shouldn't
actually say a word we'll call it you
know just xnews.com wait that's actually
probably the name of an organization
okay sure that is yeah
hypothetical non-existent news
organization perfect
and let's say it gets 10 million views
per month they want to sell
ads but that's not a whole lot of
traffic
yeah what they do is they license the
rights to
views from click farms so you'll get you
know
a generic clip click farm website that
will be like
look at all these pictures of you know
tom cruise like smiling
and then it'll say like 25 photos of
crazy celebrity photos
and every time you click one it makes
you reload a new page because that turns
one person
one article into 25 pages 25 pages dude
it's like then
here's what happens the news
organization then buys the rights to
those
views and claims there are views and all
of a sudden now
this small news outlet is getting a
hundred million views per month
crazy so so you know he was saying
there's gonna be a bloodbath
i said these companies don't realize
they're on the way out and their views
even cable tv are going down
down down every day i know we saw a big
spike because of trump
but it's going down they're bleeding
it's consolidating a lot of ways
but it's it's it's like in order for the
new york times survive it must create
more entropy around it than than you
know
in the gates to put it this way you
might have 100 million subscribers to
news outlets
nationwide through all the different
local outlets
but most people are canceling those
subscriptions and the new york times is
picking up only
some of them everyone else is getting
news for free from rage bay trash
so the new york times might see its
subscribers up a few million as the
country sees total subscriptions go down
they're going to lose their influence
they're going to make good money and
they're gonna start
thrashing about violently once they
realize they're drowning
it's like when you know when uh someone
starts suffocating and they start just
violently flailing and freaking out
that's what we're gonna see from the
media yeah but
that's what we are seeing it's like if
it's a boat that's sinking and they're
looking around the ocean all
desperately scanning the horizon they
see far up in the distance some chaos
they zoom in on it
they copy it and then they blast it out
on the airwaves over and over and over
again it's this tiny dot in the far
distance in one direction
but they're making it seem like it's the
center focus exactly
so i'll tell you what we get from this
i mentioned this you know when i did my
algorithmic psychosis rant you know last
week or whatever
that people end up growing up living in
this world where the only news they get
is that all cops are bad all cops are
racist and it's because like you said
ian
they're looking in there they're looking
in this far they're all this vast ocean
and they see this one tiny dot
and it's the only thing they're showing
to people check out this story from the
daily mail
minnesota 4th graders are given equity
survey on race and gender
and are told by teacher not to skip
questions even if they don't understand
them
and not to tell their parents let me
just show you one of the questions
number 46 do you currently identify
yourself as female male transgender
transgender people have a gender
identity or gender expression that
differs from their assigned sex
for example they were born male but now
identify as female or something else
and you can choose female male
transgender non-binary
why is a fourth grader being told to
first of all out themselves the teacher
should they actually have
a you know a trans or non-binary
identity why
why are the kids being handed this stuff
on equity in this survey
given these questions what i think is
these teachers
likely millennials grew up getting
exposed to the social media over the
past 10 years
nothing but extremist content that
generated rage
their whole world view was built on it
and now they're giving it to the kids
they are transferring that tenfold to
children
who are not going to have the same
opportunity to have
you know millennials didn't completely
grow up on the internet to a great deal
they did but i know a lot of people who
didn't get internet until they were late
teenagers
at least you had some opportunity to use
a phone mounted to the wall you know
touch tone phone
word yeah right yeah it took you 10
minutes to write one paragraph these
little kids
are not only going to grow up on social
media being inundated with nothing but
critical race applied principles but
they're going to be getting it from
their teachers as well
and you know what i can't remember i
can't remember who it was i should i
should write down the quotes but someone
on the show said
parents don't care about their children
at all
and it's because and the example is that
they're being sent off to
institutionalized learning facilities
where the parents don't know what
they're being taught
don't know what they're being exposed to
and to a great deal don't care
a lot of parents do care steve bannon's
bet is that come august 15th when the
parents find out what's going
on they're gonna lose it but i think
it's a really good point if you think
about it
parents say i'm gonna send my kids to
school
and then hope for the best now by all
means i understand some people may have
normalized this behavior
some people probably get really offended
by me saying that saying tim you don't
have kids you know you're talking about
but i can say this if you are not at the
very least actively
asking your children what is going on at
school show me your assignments show me
your books
then i don't think you really care what
strength spending time with them god
forbid
well yeah but that's like obviously if
you care about your kids spend time with
them what i'm saying is
i get it send your kids to school i
think there's issues i think you should
homeschool i think we should do more
more of the pod learning i was
homeschooled quite a bit
i think if you were really concerned
about what schools were doing to your
kids you would for one
be very you'd pay a whole lot of
attention to the school boards you'd pay
attention to the school curriculums and
a lot of parents do
i think a lot of parents don't and
that's probably why they're they're the
more lefty democrat voters don't you're
saying though
like don't you see pushback in american
society right now against what you're
talking about
and like this goes back to what you're
saying critical theory is a critique
right
what do you mean by pushback well i'm
saying all of the
school board meetings that are going
viral and you know all these parents and
these kids and
teachers speaking out and the way in
which you know
this whole concept of critical theory is
a big company
how many conversation right now i agree
how many school board battles
are there right now well that's how the
tide turns though it's like we're
just you know we're at high tide right
now and it's shifting do you know how
many school board battles there are
i don't know i'm not trying to put you
on the spot i'm genuinely asking if you
were familiar because i don't have the
answer
uh i have a general it's a good question
i mean we run them all the time because
i think it's
you know it's a it's a government feed
so you can it's non-commercialized so
you can just run it as is
have you have you guys seen any hard
numbers and how many school boards are
and
i've seen one article that mentioned it
was like between six and seven hundred
school boards are in how many are there
in like total there are
85 uh i'm sorry 98 271 public grade
schools
as of between 2013 and 2014.
98 000. so we hear these stories and
we're like the parents are fighting back
yes at how many schools
out of the nearly hundred thousand
schools
are the k the kids are all being
indoctrinated i tell you this right now
that fourth grader is what nine years
old yeah nine more years until she votes
for a marxist
if you're a teacher and you're telling
the kids not to talk to their parents
you are enacting child abuse i'm that
kid that kid
has a right and a duty to communicate
with its parents
if you're a parent ask your kid what
they learned at school today but that's
exactly what they're doing
we saw that it's like you're lying
people are
not encourage your kids to lie to their
parents i think parents don't care about
their kids
why would you think that because what
you've been told lately
i was homeschooled i was i was
homeschooled
before kindergarten and then i went to
i went to a private catholic school
until the end of fifth grade
my parents transferred me to public
school for a few years my grades slipped
a little bit
then in the first few months of high
school
my parents asked what was going on and
when they saw the negative impacts they
immediately pulled us out
and homeschooled us again because my
parents genuinely in my opinion
cared and they sent us to school because
it's you know school i mean it's what
you do
but they were always very active we
would we were going when we were at
catholic school we were going to mass
and then when we stopped when when we
switched to public school there was a
lot less
family interaction with with the school
system but the reason i think i would
say parents don't care about their kids
is that how often have you heard of the
trope where the kid says
my teacher hates me and the parent says
oh shut up geez
you've heard that trope before right you
know it's like no it's not fair my
teacher hates me
oh come on you're just not doing your
work the the the point where parents
don't trust their own children when they
say i'm having problems in school
not every parent does this i'm not
saying every single parent i'm saying
there are many parents who are like go
to school i have no idea what they're
telling you
i have no idea what you're learning i
have no idea if you're gonna be a good a
good person
or you're gonna hold my values or have a
good life i have no idea what goes on in
that building for those eight hours or
whatever you're there
i bet it has to do with stress you know
how they say if someone goes out and
works 12-hour days and they're exhausted
when they get home
they have no time to talk about politics
they only care about where the food is
and that's it the basic life so if the
parent is stressed about money and
they're working
a job the two jobs that can't really
even pay the bills they're going to be
too stressed
or have this layer of stress that's
interfering with their communication
with their kids
they are using school as daycare yes
that is not a good thing this is a
problem
i mean but you know don't you think that
our like the public school system wasn't
exactly like rosie before this
yeah it's like based around a factory
there's literally like a bell that's
like
go to the next class so like what kind
of i agree no
is that the kind of environment that's
going to create a critical thinking
individual
no but i encourage the employees of tim
cass to bring their kids to work
as often as they can and they'll uh they
can hang out and you know
just you got to have some parenting
don't let them spill milk on the carpet
or something like that
but i not not only was i homeschooled
but when my mom opened a coffee shop on
the north side of chicago
which look you know we were like a lower
middle class family and this was like
very devastating for my family in terms
of loans it didn't work and then we went
you know my family got bankrupt and
stuff like that
but when when my mom opened a coffee
house i was nine years old and i had to
go work there
so i was sitting around next to a bunch
of adults talking politics i was getting
exposed to the real world
so it's not treating you like an adult
they're not treated like oh hello little
guy we need to cuddle you
right you know they were treating me
like an adult and to an extent
they were treating like an adult you
know it's like when you're working would
they wouldn't be
like oh it's so cute that you're trying
to wash the dishes they'd be like can
you finish the dishes because we've got
a bunch of waters coming and we need
these mugs you know what though that can
go overboard because i'm just laughing
as you're saying this because um
you want to know why i always super glue
myself instead of getting stitches and
going to the hospital
it's because when i was like six years
old my dad was like all right let's go
do my week on rounds at the hospital
this guy i'll never forget i walk into
this room and the guy's like in a full
um cast like his whole body it was like
like almost like out of a cartoon like
his arms are in a full cast he's like
all the way up to his neck he's like hey
doc how are you doing
hold on one sec rich i got this guy an
industrial uh air conditioner fell on
him
he's like i feel great amazing i never
want to go to the hospital
that was it for me i i the socialization
that i got
growing up was very much from a lot of
adults in the workplace
like real world interactions and so i
look at what's happening to
previous generations kids the current
generations kids i mean think about this
what do kids need to be exposed to to
live good healthy fulfilling lives
they need to understand how to lead good
healthy fulfilling lives
but we have kids raise each other the
parents take the kid
and they put him in the school the
teacher mindlessly drones along with
like you know half glazed over eyes
going turn the pen
seven and the kids are sharing notes
with each other
the kids are all raising each other man
it's no surprise to me that we're seeing
cultural decay
when millennials in many ways grew up
going to schools where the teachers
mostly don't care about them their
parents mostly don't know what's going
on in these schools
the kids are going out to parties and
teaching each other things
so yeah you get like a lord of the flies
type scenario these kids grow up they
get power and then it's just like who's
got the conch bashing people over the
head
i grew up surrounded by people working
jobs and working in businesses
and i'm here i am running a business you
know
it's funny you say that because i i got
major lord of the flies vibes when i was
in the jazz
it was like the kids leading the kids
yeah exactly and it was and that's why
they don't understand what work is where
money comes from
they're just like i swear i was i was
arguing with people who are
pro-ubi and i gave the simple argument
of if you don't make stuff
there is no stuff and they were like
what are you talking about like there's
stuff in stores
and then i was like yeah but somebody
had to make that stuff and they're like
what do you mean it's just there
and i was like no way dude what are you
legit telling me you don't know what
supply chain is
i actually had an argument with someone
who told me the electricity was just
there in the walls
that's actually mark levin he has a
great
um i forget which book it is he's
written so many so many books
um but he he basically he tracks the
supply chain of a pencil
that's cool it's a graphic pencil and
how complex how many different
sources of manufacturers etc and how
hard it is to collectivize that and
centrally plan it
rather than just allow basically the
marketplace to figure out how to make
that supply chain work
you can't centralize it that's why
communism doesn't work
but you look at these young people what
happens they're placed in
institutionalized learning facilities by
their parents without a thought
they then have a teacher who tells them
what to do and when they do it and they
say okay
the food it's food time they walk in the
room and there's food
and then they go home their whole lives
and you've got people who go to school
until what 22 or 24
their entire lives some of these kids
never had a job in their life
they have no idea what production is so
when they get out of school they're
simply like
where is the authority figure telling me
what to do and giving me food
so they demand the government do it and
that's they're voting for right now
and if parents wanted their kids to be
successful to be able to survive to have
their values
they would be communicating with them
every day they'd be working with them
and and very much to a great degree
taking them out of these schools
when you get these four-year-olds who
are being given these these cult surveys
about creepy stuff
you shouldn't be asking kids or there
was that one teacher who was
playing the video for kids about how to
you know take care of business on your
own
we keep it family friendly i guess out
of your it
yeah yes yes huh it wasn't a how-to it
was just a
this happens to occur oh you're talking
about that cartoon yeah
yeah that was creepy right it was really
weird but think about the parents
think about the parents who are like i
had no idea they were doing it to my
kids
now when parents found out about it they
freaked out well plus don't you think
it's also
i don't know there's a certain
corruptive factor of having the internet
like literally
hear that you know
if we're talking about lord of the flies
the loss of innocence that happens to a
ten-year-old kid the moment
that they go to the website that their
buddy told like i had to download it off
napster i was like
all right four days later i got this
like thirty-five dude
you know video of me or whatever i stole
this song that has swears in it you know
early 90s comp you serve and it's like
this song will download in 14 hours
yes two kilobits per second or you're
like a box of magazines or whatever you
know in like
your uncle's closet and like that's your
that's your moment of loss of innocence
south america it's still two kilobits a
second in the jungle
not with starling when that comes nation
global time is relative have you ever
seen the time machine
the movie yeah or read the book i read
the book yeah you know like he goes to
the far future and there's like the one
super intelligent guy and then a bunch
of the like cavemen and they're two
distinct species now
yeah that's basically what's happening
you look at these tech elites
the foods they eat the way they live
their lives the things they have access
to
and the things regular people do the way
they live their life live their lives
and what they have access to
it really just feels like take a look at
their kids the children of the tech
elites do not have phones or internet
tablets they don't give it to them i
wonder why mark zuckerberg
takes the camera and microphone on his
computer knows what's in the sausage
that's right yeah it's like it's like
they know soylent green is people
yeah everybody else is eating with a
smile on their face they're like don't
look at me i'm letting that stuff i
don't want encephalopathy or whatever
encephalitis whatever it's called i mean
i think that's that's what can be taken
i mean that's what i take from the last
year which is like
you see the the everything that we're
talking about right now it manifests
itself on the streets with these sad
desperate people who are out there
because they're desperate
and whatever side of the political
spectrum they're on they're desperate
because they feel like the system has
failed them
and probably because it has and nobody's
addressing that nobody's addressing
the actual everybody says it's either
systemic racism or it's
cancel culture but nobody's like whoa
hold on this is just two different hands
of the same issue here you think
maybe the uh the government's failures
will result in more people becoming
libertarian
it's like like i was saying these kids
go to school right the system provides
now they're out of school and they're
like where's the system they tell them
to do and give me food
and then when they realize it failed
maybe they'll be like i better find food
on my own
well i think back to what we basically
started with which is
what did you say you said uh technology
in technology is downstream
culture culture is downstream from so
now what's happening is
like trump definitely usurped the whole
cultures politics is downstream from
culture because i think he kind of just
like
you know maybe there would have been a
trumpian figure elected in a couple of
years if he hadn't just like literally
hijacked that election um so i think you
know that kind of came to the
forefront earlier than it would have
otherwise but
no matter what we're still it's still
culture and politics are both catching
up with technology we're just playing
catch up
and the tech the tech monopolies are the
ones who are capitalizing on that
ian makes a really good point that that
culture is downstream from technology
look at what happens with the radio
you have mass communications the
printing press the printing press allows
for the mass dissemination of propaganda
for an american revolution
you eventually you know you get hundreds
of years of that basically but more and
knowledge is being spread people's
attitudes and their understandings
change
the radio creates a new culture of radio
the style of speaking
the the you know you get silent films
then films
as more it's it's communication
technology really that i think is
driving culture in a lot of ways
the rapid spread of behaviors and
information now we get the internet
which has dramatically altered our
culture in a lot of crazy ways
i think a lot of really bad ways and i
think a lot of really good ways it's not
simple to say one or the other
how do we deal with the bad element the
slamming beating kids over the face with
you know critical race applied
principles
how do we get rid of that bad stuff and
keep the good stuff of kid
you can google it to figure it out for
yourself but you can't really now
because google kind of controls
exactly right you can bing it you can
duck you can go to the library i think
you're better off just going to the
library
now they're banning books dude you can
look at how corporations
control the the narrative with their
censorship so that's a problem that
needs to be looked at you look at other
technologies like
fiat currency currency in general as a
technology the
the way the currency is utilized is a
problem that's altering culture in a
massive way oh yeah like
with with the federal reserve it changed
the way people could buy houses what
they could own what they could trade
and it gave centralized authority to a
small group
we have centralized electric grids so
we're we're at the whim
of the government because if they want
to turn the power off we're screwed that
we have centralized water systems
they want to shut the water off we're
screwed so
these technologies are big problems and
i think if we holistically focus on all
of them
we might be able to to seize the culture
but focusing on one of them is just
going to be ramming ahead into a wall no
but it's it's
you got you got to go for the uh the
grassroots
you you're not gonna be able to come out
and be like hey everybody let's totally
decentralize all infrastructure it's
gonna be like
well like who's working on what but if
we were like let's figure out a way to
get everybody energy independent let's
figure out a way to give everybody
community independent communications
no one can shut your phone off no one
can ban you no one can silence you how
do we do that
communications is easy for us because
we're all kind of communications people
you know like here we are on an internet
show talking
but what about energy what about fuel or
food resources how do we get people to
become
decentralized which means a lot of
personal responsibility
we need more polymaths among us like ben
franklin
and uh thomas jefferson it's funny
though because when you're describing
like what the media is doing and how
they're like packaging up with these
click farms and stuff like that
i was thinking to like you know 2008 the
way that they packaged up all these
subprime mortgages
and just sold them no you're right
they're like oh yeah they're triple a
and it's like
it's all good as long as you know you
keep you can keep selling the house for
a little bit more
it's okay until all of a sudden you know
those were international scams
but mortgage scandal was an insurance
scandal they didn't want to classify it
as insurance because they avoided all
the litigation that would have come
along with it but they were basically
that they're buying insurance what do
you mean uh uh
subprime mortgage there is an insurance
the mortgage-backed securities the
mortgage
those are insurance packages if the more
if they can't get paid back on the
mortgage so the triple-a
aaa rating is the likelihood of it to
default so so so they were buying their
shirts
all that crap so they weren't talking
about talking about media you're exactly
right richie because i was actually uh
working on
the preliminary documentary about this
the ad rights assignment stuff isn't as
prominent as it was as it is today so
it's not as relevant but we could maybe
do a look back
what they were doing was they were
taking bunk views that were worthless
and then packaging them behind aaa rated
news websites
so everybody knows that you know this
website is the gold standard of youth
news
yeah wow 100 million views when it was
really getting 30 million and 70 million
was
garbage views from trash clickbait
websites
where you'd click in and you'd bounce
out in five seconds but that
that was a click and then you by
contract assign the traffic rights
to the aaa rated company who then goes
to advertisers and says
we get a 100 million views per month if
you want some of this it's going to cost
you 50 grand for an ad
and then the companies are like wow 100
million views we'll buy it
but then the campaigns didn't work you
can't sell ads to nobody
so eventually the bubble burst i mean
that's
that's fraud i mean facebook as if you
compare it as a
social media ecosystem compared to like
youtube or even instagram
people like an average view time
on facebook is like you know a good one
is like 20 something seconds it's like
wow
wow that's so good it was over 20
seconds yeah like youtube what's your
average view time on your show
uh i think it's uh on this channel like
28
to 30 minutes really exactly and then on
my other channels it's like 14
between 10 and 14 depending on you know
so there are still places where people
can go to like
get qualitative content that they're
actually paying attention to where there
actually is value
and that's you know there are people are
learning that there are ways of
measuring that
so i don't think like it's you know you
know it's a bubble that's going to burst
necessarily
i think we've got a
our culture is no longer focused you
know
it's it's it's what is it doing it's
like a frankenstein culture
it's got one squid arm and like a peg
leg
it's a half pirate monster just ninja
squid frankenstein frankenstein three
werewolf three classes
in the culture you got the banking class
the merchant class and then
i guess you call it the lower class oh
no you've got the text
class then you've got the communications
class they're all political classes all
merchants
there's the bankers which are running
everything then there's the merchants
which are sucking off
and basically funding and capitalizing
they're like business owners and things
like that
and then there's all the workers that's
that's i completely disagree
one of the most annoying things about
occupy wall street was when this guy
stood up and screamed during a general
assembly fracking
is the problem it's the center of
everything
and then i busted out laughing like this
guy is so myopic
in his view that he thinks fracking is
the problem
i mean we can start with the federal
reserve that i can give you but to claim
that small business owners and amazon
are in the same merchant class is just
completely incorrect
to claim that both merchants mark
zuckerberg
who is in the same class as a
mom-and-pop candy shop is is not
not it is not sound doesn't make sense
you've got tech
elites who manipulate what people can
and can't do the communications
companies who can take who can shut off
your cell phone
who can track your cell phone who can
give your information to the government
you've got the intelligence agencies
the permanent government then you've got
the political class the liars who get
voted
there are so many different groups of
people all all colluding to extract
value from the system that's why i
called it a mass frankenstein monster
of various cultures all just shambling
around
falling it's going to fall over what was
once you know it's this it's the ship of
theseus
that's probably the best way to describe
it i'm familiar with theseus yes
so so uh the the uh right the ship of
theseus i'm talking about right that i'm
thinking of theseus was the guy with the
golden fl
the golden fleece you know the the ship
is that you know how many if you take
take one piece off and replace it how
long until
i thought he he slayed the minotaur
right i don't know anything about his
book is it is it theseus
i don't know i don't remember i'm sorry
you lost me i think it is familiar with
that
let's see what the commenters are saying
let's find out our audiences
yeah okay yeah i'm right yeah so the
ship of theseus is that let's save a
boat
and then you remove one piece of wood
and then and replace it with a brand new
piece of wood
is it still the ship of theseus that's
how he got home
now you replace it with another piece of
wood do that until
all of the original pieces have been
removed and replaced is it still the
original ship of theseus
then take the remaining pieces and
rebuild the ship of theseus now you have
two which one's the real one
it's an interesting thought well boats
don't have souls
well so here's the issue countries do
yeah and so
if from the start of the american uh
country experiment they want to call it
we had the ship of america
and one by one we've replaced parts and
put in different parts
the problem is they're not the same
piece if you had like a 12x4 piece of
wood plank and removed it with like a
three by nine it's not gonna work
properly
and now we're at the point where we have
not rebuilt the ship of theseus
we've created this weird amalgam of
competing interests that's shambling
along and starting to sink
i don't know i'm maybe more optimistic
because i i think back
like just a generation or two ago i mean
we literally had a global war we had a
cold war where everybody thought they
were going to get
nuked and talk about the red scare talk
about being scared about communism
taking over america
i mean that was literally like bro the
threat of
annihilation was like you wanted to get
on your desk and just prepare to get
vaporized you're right at every turn and
one of those superpowers
collapsed and does that mean the united
states could not be facing the same
thing
we're facing collapse and then china
wins is what you're saying maybe it's a
new cold war and who says we're going to
win it but i think you know
i like to think that america's and the
constitution is more resilient
it's like the ship that you're talking
about the constitution ensures that we
can
you know revise and and open free and
open society ensures that we can
correct ourselves and the tide can ebb
and flow between you know whatever you
want to call it left and right
libertarian
authoritarian i love the constitution
but where was the constitution when jake
gardner
was being threatened and his family was
being attacked and then he got choked
i never yeah i never said it was perfect
and like that situation is so
devastating
that's not the fault of the constitution
that's why i said earlier you can have
the law
and then you have the culture and if the
culture doesn't support the law the law
doesn't make any sense or doesn't matter
so when black lives matter can literally
go around destroying buildings causing
two billion thousand damage and face
no repercussions and gains support from
all the major massive multinational
corporations
the law doesn't matter does it but dude
we had we had the bill of rights when
there were still slaves like there was
that
right like the law didn't matter but it
was the culture it changed
and the culture changed and and
generally the culture
bent in the direction of actual genuine
progress and in the in the
in the moment where you're in between
the waves you know it's really hard to
see over the next one but
you know if you take a much broader view
of american history you realize like
wow like every generation thought that
they were in this dire crisis and they
thought that america was doomed and yet
it's so resilient and it's like i think
it's partially a byproduct of like
you know like you said the soul the
country does have a soul and it is this
i don't i think the american dream is
still alive and so far as people still
come here
because so for a reason and people
aren't flooding into china our
understanding of free speech is new
right 100 years ago free speech didn't
exist the way we think it does
so the bill of rights almost didn't
matter you had a very moralistic
authoritarian style of culture you can't
say these things you can't dress this
way
now we have a very very libertarian but
the problem is
a new moral authoritarianism is on the
rise of course the united states will
exist probably in name but who knows
what it'll actually be
right like you mentioned when the bill
of rights was created they were slaves
right because the bill of rights didn't
matter so much as the culture mattered
what the people willing to tolerate and
willing to do so we can talk about
making the country better and moving
towards freedom
which is what i think we've typically
done the problem is now
the dominating faction is anti-freedom
and pro-collectivist
which means we're going backwards in
fact these people
outright want to rewind the clock on
civil rights i'll give you the easiest
example to understand
so people can so people can truly
understand what's happening okay
ibrahim ex-candy the anti-the guy who
the anti-racism guy
what's his real name though i don't know
i thought it was even henry
it's henry rodgers yeah i think oh it is
shout out to henry rodgers is it henry
rogers it's true yeah he's also a guy
i only know that because a guy at the
daily caller so alexandria ocasio-cortez
he's like the whitest guy ever so it's
funny alexandria ocasio-cortez says
why don't peop these republicans you
know want schools to teach the kids to
be anti-racist
anti-racist i love that word anti-race
so smart
because people who have no idea what's
going on say oh i hate racism
i want to be anti-racist but what does
candy say
he says anti-racism the only solution
for past discrimination
is present discrimination and the only
solution for present discrimination
is future discrimination right that's an
ibrahim that's a quote from kennedy
he genuinely believes we should have
racial discrimination
now i think discriminating on the basis
of race is evil
don't you i think most people agree with
that in america okay
so let's replace discrimination with
evil so kendy's statement is
the only solution to past evil is
present evil and the only solution to
present evil is future evil
why would i want someone who is evil to
have any power at all well
discrimination is not evil
it can be used in an evil way but you
have to discriminate if you have a hot
rock and a cold rock
you know that you don't want to pick up
the hot rock you have to discriminate
between the rocks as to which one is
safe to touch
so i'm i'm obviously not being 100
absolute i am making a point using
hyperbole
and exaggerating clearly there are
instances where general discrimination
doesn't mean discriminate against human
beings you know but
you need someone to pick the apples up
there you gotta you gotta hire the tall
guy
which is right right right so i i think
the issue with like that frame of
thinking is
most people probably understand my point
but arguing the semantics of it doesn't
actually i don't think
i don't think there's a lot of
situations where discriminating on race
has any value
can you think of one medical uh sickle
cell yeah yeah so there are times when
you need to discriminate based on race
for people's safety
what i'm saying is that ibram kendy's
view is that we should form
policies that affect people's lives and
access to civil rights
based on their race when my view is
mostly a negative rights aspect of
we should not impose restrictions based
on their race so they can always enjoy
full civil rights
now of course the left argues but
they're not being allowed full civil
rights because of racism and i'm like
private actors do private things and
they're bad people
the system has already been healing from
this for 50 was it 56 57 years
they they complain about you know these
these uh
redlining and blockbusting and i'm like
yes we have been solving for that
it's not perfect we've passed the laws
now we're trying to solve that problem
but you
are now bringing us back you're saying
you are
going to bring back racial
discrimination i'm like you're making
things worse but don't you think okay
but you know don't you think that the
the same
tide that ebden flowed in order to allow
for the civil rights
movement and i'm not drawing the same
parallel i'm just speaking in terms of
cultural shifts you know the mainstream
the the people who are
quote unquote revolutionaries trying to
change the system actually able
to create you know progress quote
unquote and obviously that's a charged
term
but don't you think that most people
don't think
in america don't think like iran x candy
and it's just that everybody's scared to
speak up right now right because
they have a fear of you know that their
digital self
being maligned to the point where their
real self is you know
they are from society they are more
scared of being called a racist
than of their children being
indoctrinated into a moralistic
authoritarian
i think that's i think that's generally
right but
it's still america and it's not did the
people in the social security
russia but the soviet union sucked it
was a [ __ ] system
and america is the best system that's
ever made flawed as it may be
and sorry that i
irrelevant the soviet union was garbage
and the people hated it
and it stood for 100 years yes the
united states system is an amazing
system
but people still are doing nothing to
stop the central planners and the
communists from seizing power
so hey american marxism mark levin's
book sold 500 000 copies in like a week
yeah there's and we see a lot of amazon
number ones
800 school boards they're up in arms
about it this show focuses on it there's
98
000 schools bro yeah but only you'll
need 5 000 of them then you only need
five percent of them
yes i think i i kind of agree in that in
so far as like
it only takes a few people to stand up
to a corrupt system like soldier
nietzsche
who wrote the gulag archipelago and was
able to bring
the whole system down based upon one man
who stood up and
literally how the hell he memorized the
whole thing no i'm not
no no i'm going to incredible it only
takes one of those incredible people now
i'm gonna make sense
saying the exact same verbatim quote
right now
and that means it's a coin toss i don't
think it's a coin toss because i don't
think
ultimately it doesn't matter what the
ideology is behind it it's like
common sense is common sense and and
they're saying the same thing
and if people are scared to speak up and
talk about what they believe and they're
willing to cower
then you've got one violent faction
who's been given carte blanche because
the establishment rarely if ever says
anything bad about them
and another faction that is being
persecuted and prosecuted to a growing
and more extreme degree
so you're right you know what's what's
the saying from
what's that woman you know let never be
said that a small group of determined
people have you know couldn't change
history indeed it's the only thing they
never have
sure but that's also true of your
political opponents
you know history is written by the
victors and you look at what happens in
you know throughout history with civil
wars and
and conquest and the people who are able
to win and write the books down and
spread
those ideas are the ones who win right
now you have a growing faction of
extremist
critical race theorists and their
critical race applied principles
and you have a much smaller group of
people who are willing to actually stand
up
and challenge it there are a lot of
people willing to challenge it
there are more people by the day but
there's also more anti-for people
it was it was eight percent progressive
according to the hidden tribes report
three years ago the the last poll i
checked it was like 10
10 or 11 percent they've grown they've
gone to power for a few reasons
they're getting more young people like i
mentioned those fourth graders
nine more years and you will have fully
fledged adult marxists
who believe all that stuff and it's
their whole whole life that's
if we don't do anything about it yeah i
mean i would look to like europe or
canada and like
you know jordan peterson being a good
example of like we were talking about
one person standing up i mean he was the
only guy in the entire education system
uh in canada who's like whoa oh you're
compelling our speech and you want to
like make it criminal for me not to you
know
say if i make him whatever if you say
the wrong pronoun i think it was
basically
you you could be criminal and if you
don't pay your fine you can't go to jail
and so he stood up against it and look
at what happened you know
there was this like global support that
came behind him
solely because he was that one guy
willing to stand up and and that's in
like much more
you know i think less free societies
than we live in
so i think the tide's shifting dude and
i feel good about this sure sure what
i'm saying is
in nine years we will have that that
fourth grader a fully fledged marxist
obviously it's if we do nothing the
point is we're here trying to do
something people need to pay attention
they need to understand what what it
means to get involved they need to
understand what it means to speak up at
their workplace
challenge these systems refuse to
support them if
you know a company wants to get woke
they can go broke one guy messaged me
and he's like i listen to the show every
night with my two daughters one's 10 and
one's 13 and the 10 year old asked them
something they were all listening to in
the car and the 10 year old asked
something then the 13 year old was like
it doesn't matter the government's going
to fall apart anyway
we're seeding these thoughts into kids
so we got to be careful
conscious about what we say what we want
to happen
and how we frame things i don't think
personally that there are more
and i don't think that this stupid
racist movement is growing
i think that it showed its head it's
obviously deranged
most people see that you know what ian
you're right and my biggest fear is that
you know if if we don't do something
then then the libertarians are going to
take over and
dave smith will become president oh man
oh man worst case scenario we're seeding
these ideas
oh no we don't do anything the mises
caucus and the libertarian party are
gonna
are gonna take over i'm kidding that'd
be great
you're right the stakes are high though
and i agree that it's not it's nothing
that's it's not a trivial
thing and it's not something that people
just should just say oh you know it's
just happening
in you know blue check twitter zone
because
um i think you know all of us are kind
of the byproduct of i don't know how old
are you i'm like 42.
you're 42. looks great right what the
are you kidding me in the 70s how did
you think he was
i don't know 36. definitely not yeah i
don't know
well growing up because i think you know
being born in 89
we're about the same age like i was
definitely part of the generation of
everybody gets a trophy
that's for sure yeah me too and like i
don't know no i wasn't you're like a rub
you're rubbing some dirt get a job when
you're 12.
yeah yeah we're not paying you allowance
anymore go out there you know it was one
of the
walking dog one of the worst feelings i
ever had remember i was in third grade
and they were doing this like thing at
my school where there was like
it was like an after-school program
thing like parents were there and they
were asking trivia questions and i was
just a little smart kid right
so i would raise my hand but the teacher
would never call on me and so i started
crying
because i didn't get a chance to
actually answer the question and win the
prize
so i was just a given one and i was like
that was like the most brutal thing ever
it felt
miserable i was like i don't want it i
must have i wanted to answer the
question
i missed it by like by like six years or
something i think the internet
i don't know what what brought that on
that everybody gets a trophy
it's uh well i think it's actually what
tim was talking about earlier which is
that
the people who uh basically occupied the
positions of you know being our teachers
were the children of that that kind of
counterculture movement of the late 60s
you know they're basically hippies
they're the ones who went into
humanities to teach your kids english
and
whatever commies you know teach your
kids how to how to critically think
but we still you know we still read like
uh
tom sawyer and stuff like we still had
to contend with those difficult topics
and
and that's right and we still gotta
contend with these super chats
oh all right yeah we're gonna go to
super chat someone's gonna call me out
about saying trump did cocaine with
strippers i'm sorry i don't know that he
ever did that i was just i've just heard
that he was a party boy
if someone came to me and said would you
like to place a bet
to as to whether or not trump did
cocaine with a bunch of hookers i'd be
like i will take that i will take that
time
like how much can i give you all of my
money yes so uh
smash the like button subscribe to the
channel go to timcast.com
i'm going to shout out the leguma
someone someone super chatted us because
i was like star trek's so great and they
were like watch stargate and i was like
okay now all the star trek references
are stargate references so that's that's
how the show
started watching stargate yeah okay good
it's good and then someone said to watch
um
farscape is that what they haven't seen
it yet i don't know
a lot of portal uh sliders quantum leaps
portals
sliders isn't quantum leap though oh boy
all right trip sucks says richie you
inspire me i just thought you should
know how loved and valued you truly are
oh wow thank you thank you it's all
worth it
this is a really this is a really great
chat right here pierce wurzig says tim i
work in a grocery store and i've been
noticing that a lot of the new products
are coming in as smaller packages
sizes like family size or large size are
an ounce or two smaller than the product
already on the shelf
i noticed that interesting i went i went
shopping the other day
and the family size uh box of cereal
was like a normal box of cereal it was
the weirdest thing
and i was like this is not families
that's tiny same price same price that's
inflation
yeah another kind of inflation because
they know people aren't going to be able
to pay more
they reduce what the average size of the
family in america has shrunk
that's true and probably bigger than
that our population is increasing is
because of it
bottles are getting smaller there was
they're like 64 ounces or now 59 ounce
wow you're shrinking everything yeah and
one of them one of the best things i
love this
when they keep the box the exact same
size oh but the stuff inside is smaller
rude these are great chips too yup as
long as my quarter pounder
remains a quarter pound yeah that's like
a quarter pounder is a half pound by the
way
mccarthy 86 says the 1994 stargate movie
was better than sg-1 series changed my
mind they're different
they're just different you know start
getting s james spader
yeah i like the movie james spader good
job james
all right let's see chris blank
production says tim to address your
earlier video about the stages of
genocide
we've voluntarily done stage seven by
anyone not okay with what's happened to
the cities fleeing the red states
putting them all in one place well
they're not all in one place
that's that's the us versus them
separation so
that's why i don't think it's right when
people are like we're so close to
genocide i'm like
we're close to a balkanization or a
civil conflict
but what does close even really mean you
know are we going to like crop dust it
and then pull out the last minute and
then everything calms down
maybe i gotta be honest
i i can look you know uh uh
i can i i can look at a at a problem and
try and come up with a solution
i can look at something and saying here
here here or what i think are some
possibilities
and i can do really well at magic the
gathering when i'm holding the cards in
my hand and i can make some predictions
about what's going to happen what i can
do
i look at the system and the pieces we
have we're given the cards were dealt in
this culture war and i'm like
you explain to me how you're going to
get a maga hat wearing trump supporter
who's you know protesting masks vaccines
and
and he's protesting in defense of the
january 6 writers that person
and you're going to get the pink hat
wearing you know twitter roddy anti-gun
person
to shake hands and agree to calm down
that'd be cool yeah we're getting there
we're getting there
i i don't see that um i see that getting
worse than that it's darkest before now
that's true that's true which means we
might crop dust it we don't know where
the bottom is gonna be well let's
how about this i was at the cuban
protest today in front of the white
house
and i didn't want to give it away when
we were talking before but guess what
happened
everybody was out there protesting
libertad libertad right
the secret service comes in they cleared
out lafayette square
and there was no pepper spray whatsoever
and everybody was completely peaceful
and it
and i was like waiting for it i was like
no here we go again just like the
jackson statue and they try to
nothing but these were more libertarian
protesters
yelling from um were they leftists to
support joe biden
you know it was they were very angry
though there was a lot of passion there
and i felt like they were out there
feeling like their cousins and stuff
were existentially threatened by um
you know the situation in cuba so it
wasn't like they didn't care
and it wasn't like they you know had
some particular political ideology
it was just like i don't know they were
just yeah it's not against the
american government in any way these
these well they're pros
like help cuba help actually the only
real like situation where things got
very like um you know almost to a
boiling point was actually there were
like
two or three code pink protesters who
were arguing
in favor in favor of uh basically
breaking the blockade
which is like you know basically giving
the regime a break yeah right
so the cuban the cuban freedom
protesters were like
no you got like saying the worst things
i put it on twitter like saying very
very bad things in spanish these people
and it was because you know they wanted
to
alleviate to break it was just kind of a
little bit counterintuitive and i was
like wait a second oh that i guess that
makes sense because
that's giving the regime a break and
basically you know giving them more
yeah weird situation when you read more
super chat when you when you blockade a
government
from getting goods but then you end up
screwing the populace or when you
give the government goods and they hoard
them away from the populace like it's a
lose-lose
how do you it's kind of like us hoarding
away from the super chat right now so
tim sorry
sorry guy that was coming next time
we are not responsible for the
well-being of another country just
because we say we're not going to trade
with you doesn't make it our fault it's
the stupidest communist thing i've ever
heard but let's read some more
woodworking medic says i grew up in
omaha and the suicide story makes me so
mad
omaha was rated the most dangerous place
to be black in the u.s in 2014.
that was due to black on black crime
crime from gang violence
people just don't understand how messed
up the world is getting
yeah man this story is so heartbreaking
martin la montagne says lamontagne how
do you pronounce that
the term you are looking for is
oculocracy
what a classy word oculocrisis
rule by the mobs
all right let's see robert neal says
some parallels to freedom phone in the
original tesla roadster
freedom phone is a re-badged chinese
phone the same way the tesla was just a
lotus elise with electric motors
bright future for freedom phone cool
maybe i mean
if you don't want to deal with learning
how to hack a phone and it's not
particularly difficult honestly to like
flash a new
operating system on your phone or rom
and you can get graphene and stuff but
most people don't know how to
lame i'm sorry tim yeah yeah they're no
fun why
because go-karts are fun and like when
you stomp on something it makes a loud
noise and you're like
we got we got these electric bikes
everyone's like oh they're so fast i'm
like i don't care i want to
like shift gears and like burn rubber
and like
means manual yeah it's true i agree give
me go-kart or give me debt
thank you chubby kobold gaming says wow
the seattle mayor was just on the news
saying they need
more police yep oh wow yeah
yeah baltimore was saying that i think
too alex thunderpaw says you're naive
we're at step seven
and that's why the biden administration
is going after patriots now
uh has the biden administration forced
trump supporters to wear
hats or shirts or badges or done
anything like that
no so that's two they do it on their own
trump supporters wear hats
what they're saying are people being
forced to identify themselves are they
saying like this group of patriots must
oh you want to go to the movie theater
are you a trump supporter you got to
wear the badge
and the nice thing is you're you have
anonymity and you're voting on purpose
per u.s law because of that but you know
what though again like
just real quick uh remember there was
that whole narrative that it's like oh
the only people who are refusing the
vaccine are like white trump supporters
that died out because it wasn't true and
because actually the vaccination
like the vaccination rates in minority
communities
like turned out to be lower like so it
was
you know hispanics were lower than white
and blacks were lower than
hispanics and so then that narrative
just died on the vine because guess what
like you could a narrative can only last
for so long before
you know we it becomes like oh
no okay that's not the case yeah move on
though makeshift electric this is a
really important one guys
ian looks like wayne and garth had a
baby that's my goal
that's what you're going for he's
cultivating andreas
andreas if you guys follow the vlogs
you've seen him
put on a video on youtube and there's
like a guy walking up to a laundromat
and i was like oh it's ian and he's like
no that's that's someone else and i was
like
it it just looks like ian and he was
like no it's a different guy and i was
like
so you were friends with the guy who was
like this lanky glasses do with long
hair
and then you like traded them in for
like an ian it's like an upgrade
that's my mo baby all right poker
soldier says tim please stop calling
them liberals they're communists
the laughter communists the writer
capitalists north authoritarian south or
libertarians
it's time we address them as such
liberals
typically refers to like a traditional
establishment democrat type
leftists are socialist or communist but
left and right what do they mean
left is a reference to pro-revolution
right is a reference to not
for the revolution but then right is is
supposed to be
like economic freedom and left is
economic cooperation
and then authoritarian economic
cooperation is mandated and libertarian
is requested it's hard to maintain and
then
free market capitals but what is
authoritarian right authoritarian free
market capital it makes no sense
none of it makes sense i think the
occupy wall street people
was the revolution and still is and then
this aberration is the betrayal of the
revolution
like castro is the portrayal of the
cuban revolution
yes maybe so dragon lady says
the secret service was originally
established in 1865 to fight
counterfeiting it wasn't until the
forced death of president mckinley that
they took on the duty of protecting the
president as well
there you go interesting
some people are saying that the list
isn't patriots versus
the left it's facts versus unvax which
um
still well that was that was my point is
that like there was supposed to be a
narrative that was only trump supporters
but there is like crossover between like
this far left people who are
skeptical of the government skeptical of
the who the cdc
so you're right though it's like
where's your where's your pass where's
your passport do you have your passport
i don't you didn't bring it
it's downstairs oh god all right hayden
said
not to be too far out there but there is
a saying
if you're not liberal and young you
don't have a heart if you're not
conservative as you're conservative as
you're older you don't have a brain
swap out liben con for some more
relevant terms the left doesn't think
i've always heard it as if you're not
liberal when you're young you have no
heart
if you're not conservative when you're
older you have no head yep
doobie mcnasty says slc punk was one of
my favorite movies in my teen years
devin sawwan that acid trip was awesome
and the culmination at the end was
unreal
yeah man surreal i feel bad for bob yeah
it was a bummer
blaze 88 says it's libertarian versus
authoritarian
what is the ratio of left versus right
that are medicated
it's fair to say big pharma has already
drugged up enough people to sway the
balance
that guy likes to get drugged up have
you seen the child's name blaze what
blaze
hey hey if it comes out of the ground
blaze have you uh have you seen the
chart though showing that
very left tend to have very high rates
of mental illness
any extreme i would think yeah it
reminds me of the joker
right in in the dark knight when harvey
dent kidnaps the the
the guy posing as a cop and he's like
where is he where's the joker
and then batman grabs the coin and he's
like you think you're going to get
anything from him
he's a schizophrenic from from arkham
asylum the joker praise on people like
that
and i'm like joker a democrat
you know like about it's like a joke
right but there there is data i mean
i think it was zack goldberg opposed to
this yeah people who identify as very
very liberal or liberal have extremely
high rates of mental illness relative to
any other group
yeah well do you think that it has to do
with like well i think concert like
right had the low conservative had the
lowest well i would say
like at least today i don't know just
generally speaking liberals you know
have an idea that they need to fix the
world
and conservatives have more of a concern
with their communities and their
families right isn't that like i think
that's a
fair generalization so i mean that's
just been exacerbated i think as
you know things have diverged more and
more which is like
we need to fix this broken system and
that's all that matters and and
meanwhile you know
back at home like conservatives are like
hey i'm good yeah
i don't know i take issue with that
mental illness phrase the phrase yeah
wellness because if you're
if you're saying in an insane society
they call you crazy
and a lot of these people are are
justifiably enraged
about what the system being bought out
by the federal reserve to start okay ian
you got to stop with that because the
left has never brought up the federal
reserve you think the reason they're out
out protesting is is not because they're
poor i mean that's the reason they're
out is because they don't have money
the lockdowns destroyed people's
livelihoods they went crazy think about
like uh
and patrick swayze you know that was the
perfect dialectic right there
they're both crazy screaming about
fracking their virtues
for other people we know there's
problems but none of these people are
protesting
money they're protesting race well
they're pro testing economic disparity
and then race is the mask
well their protest the race thing has
been added on top of it but they're not
even talking about
money in many circumstances talking
about privilege yeah you're getting
they're claiming
they're claiming that oprah winfrey is
oppressed and the homeless white veteran
is the oppressor
that's not about money that's the co-op
of the route i think the route
comes from the rage of the the occupy
range it's still there pay attention to
the race so that you don't realize that
you don't know
you got no money there are a lot of
leftists who are angry with the
billionaires
you know that's why bernie happened but
now they're totally distracted i mean
they're supporting big pharma
they're getting tattoos of like pfizer
on their arm the fouchy bobbleheads
yeah come on and they're the fouchy
pizza that's like they don't care about
the
defenses
youtube's gonna cut this feat man oh
yeah
all right all right turk longwell says
look at tim with the good movie
references tonight southland tales slc
punk and danny darko
have you seen dark city or edge of
tomorrow f by edge of tomorrow is
awesome i need to see dark city i like f
biden there at the end
we need to make that movie i haven't
seen any of those i got to see dark city
i haven't seen it but
i was looking i'll watch it i'll watch
it i'll watch it tonight
fomo says please don't misstate the
pro-life stance the whole point is that
we believe it's a separate life
it's not the mother's body but a baby
that dies right that's the point
so when the conservatives are like my
body my choice and the liberals laugh
and say
no do abortion i'm like what's the
difference
like there's no there's no contradiction
there the conservatives think
the baby's body isn't from the mother so
the mother can't make the choice for the
baby
like what are you saying the left
doesn't understand
any of these concepts they don't
actually engage in these debates
they don't understand these high level
ideas they don't talk to conservatives
and they don't understand them what are
you saying exactly
what's the argument you're saying just
there pro-life people believe the baby
is alive
and the mother is alive and the mother
doesn't have a right to choose
for the baby to die when it comes to
vaccines the conservatives are saying my
body my choice which is a slogan of the
pro-choice movement
saying you can't tell me what to do with
my body the left then tells
conservatives
you're contradicting yourself because
you're pro-life because the left doesn't
understand that babies are their own
bodies
it's yeah it's it's conception it's a
life action concept
i saw the stupidest thing ever and it
was this viral on reddit and reddit is
just
bloated with really dumb young people
who never thought about this stuff and
it was like a guy saying i can
debunk pro-life in two seconds let's say
you're at a fertility clinic
forget why you're in the fertility
clinic which is for the sake of argument
and there's a vial with a thousand
viable embryos
and a and a fire breaks out and there is
a child
and you can only choose one room to go
in to save either the vial of embryos or
the baby what do you save
it happens every time you know exactly
who they're going to save
and there's like that proves the
pro-life is wrong
and he and then he's like and you know
they'll never answer the question
honestly and i'm like they'll save the
child what do you mean
like yeah they're they'll say save the
human and then the embryos wait a second
right when it comes to abortion
they're they're they're not talking
about like there's
two babies in the womb and only one can
be saved you have to make a hard choice
it's like potentiality when when there's
a living human child and embryos clearly
they're going to prioritize
the child it's still not contradictory
because they don't understand what the
conservative argument is
they don't want to i just think they
want to go on tv and be told
they're good people and they feel good
about it it's like can i am i a good
person today yes you're a good person
i mean if i tweet empty platitudes we'll
give you a treat
i think the the abortion conversation is
the one perhaps that's the
that's the most divergent because like
for example being from the northeast
like do not bring up abortion
in any northeast but yeah don't just
don't because
like thanksgiving do not bring that up
oh
i've made that mistake and it's not even
as you know it's not even me saying like
oh
you know i think that you know anybody
who
uses the plan b pill is goes to hell i'm
not saying that
i'm just like even just having a
conversation that even introduces
what about the third trimester what
about the second trimester
you know even just asking that question
you know what about babies being viable
outside of the womb now because of
technology you know at six
you know six months whatever plastic
bags what about the idea that the the
um the baby is is a created a conception
but you still have the right to kill it
well according to ralph northam you just
gotta make him feel nice after they come
out of the womb
remember he said that on the radio show
ralph northam the governor who's
who's killing it i don't know the doctor
or whatever
see the challenge i have with it is
what's the health of the mother is
that's
that's commonly you know that's that's a
huge i think
kind of moral obstacle for the pro-life
argument which is like you know in
situations where there's like rape for
example or where the mother's
life is threatened by the um you know by
maintaining that
baby as viable or fetus or whatever you
want to call it at that stage
that's that's a slippery slope
well because rape has to do with whether
or not the mother chose for you know
made it made a a decision for that baby
to even be conceived in the first place
and that's the libertarian challenge
that i have which puts me in the
libertarian pro-choice camp which is
morally difficult to put it out exactly
exactly because mandating that the
government say your body is now
occupied and you have no right to your
personal autonomy is like a
challenging position you know the
argument i guess from the conservatives
is
you would kill the baby by removing it
and i'm like that's true but
who gives that other entity a right to
my body right because the
the mom if she's got a baby and they say
it's illegal to get an abortion the mom
could just start drinking really heavily
destroy the embryo and have it abort uh
the the issue i have or stress out or
jump on the ground i mean you can do
crazy things
i'm very very obviously in the
libertarian camp on this one
and there's different libertarian
opinions obviously but then you have
the liberal modern progressive opinion
of everyone should get abortions because
babies don't matter
and they're not alive and embryos aren't
real that was the point of that you know
bringing up the tweet
was the guy viewed embryos as not being
living things and i'm like
they are but there's a literal human
child and if you're like
doing a trolley problem or something or
like spider-man's gotta save mary jane
or a school bus load of kids
sure that's totally different from
whether or not someone should get an
abortion and that's killing a baby
you know what i mean yeah i don't want
to get into a whole debate on that one
though we gotta read some more super
chats doobie mcnasty says richie is
awesome
he has a type of personal constitution
to run up run up to someone or run up on
someone with a rifle
and try to save the life of a person who
got shot regardless of the context
that's called heroism there you go
thanks doobie man
appreciate it all right let's see
nick asses had to cut a lefty friend of
five plus years out of my life
they really do take you literally not
seriously sad
in trump voice i like to put the
parentheses in trump voice said
country you whenever you say country you
got to drop the tone
in this country puerto rico puerto rico
christopher martin sorry all right
christopher mars says i was in public
school till high school force-fed and
prescribed experimental medication
some of which would give me physical
pain and was told to ignore it
i was most definitely not the only one
i've met a lot of people who've been put
through the same
is that annoying when they're like this
is how this is how it's supposed to be
and you're like it doesn't it doesn't
feel right for me
and they're like no but this is how it
is you know
go your own route do what feels right
for you well that's that's an
interesting philosophical question too
because like
there's like the paternalistic model of
of medical the medical profession which
is like basically the doctor's like
you need to do this or you're going to
hurt yourself or
kind of the more you know we're having a
conversation
and we come to the best decision
together like i feel like that's the
same thing with the government that
we're talking about right now it's like
does government just
say no this is what's best for you get
the vaccine now
and or get the abortion or whatever or
do they say
you know it breaks down into so many
aspects of life like my even my shooting
stance
i i was taking my own shooting stance
that felt natural for me
luke was helping me and he was like
repositioning me and i think like
i'm just not normal i do things
differently i
and i do them better often because i do
them differently
so sometimes you know you want to break
the mold especially when when i see
kids getting put on psyche i mean that's
a whole other that's not yeah
t home says listening to ian's argument
against piracy last friday made my
mushroom trip difficult
take more psilocybin that is awesome
dude what do you think richie
about um this is a big conversation
piracy
so if you write a song and then
sell it on itunes and then i download it
but then
copy it and give it away to everybody
for free is that theft
um are you stealing the guy who's
copying i don't know is is is
is are you selling it or you list just
listening to everything so everyone's
downloading it to listen to it for free
we'll put it back does everybody just
listen to it personally
you're selling a song and then instead
of downloading it people all just start
downloading it from a torrent site for
free is that theft
i mean i think the people who can pay
for it are gonna pay for it because they
value the artist and i think that'll
that'll be enough
it has been enough music musicians are
rich that's not true
you know no i mean like most musicians
may what are the musicians that aren't
making money is it because of piracy
that they're not making money or is it
because the record companies decide who
are the announcements
the problem has been solved with
streaming services but for a while
yeah the uh there was a big hit to a lot
of
smaller bands income because of piracy
yeah because
i always was under the impression that
like you know during the napster days
etc it was like
you know metallica who was losing a
couple million bucks
well yeah but if you make a hundred
thousand dollars a year
and if your band is making like 200
grand a year it's five people
and you've got to split that up among
five people so everyone's getting kind
of like 40 grand or maybe you're getting
a little more they're getting a little
less
and then all of a sudden your the little
album sales you did have
all drop because people just put
everything on torrent sites
now your band breaks up you can't afford
it's a hobby now radiohead put their
album what was it hail to the thief
up for free or pay what you want it's
their highest grossing album of all time
exactly yep they pay
people are willing to pay i mean if it's
good and it's art or
news content or the question though is
is it theft
if you are saying i am selling this it
costs a dollar and then i go
i'm just gonna download it for free um
can i pass on that question can i pat
can i pass
you don't have to answer a question
someone wants you to
ian says it's not theft i'm gonna pass
the reason i say it's different than
theft because when you steal
um colloquially it's i take it away from
you and you don't have it anymore but if
i copy
your thing it's different than stealing
it kind of like if you break into an
office and steal
top secret plans or intellectual
property it's not really theft right
if you make a copy of someone's data
it's different than taking it away from
them you won't be charged with with with
theft of
intellectual property if you sneak into
a laboratory and take photographs of it
yeah you and then if you sell it to a
foreign government it's also not illegal
that's not stealing
that's fair use parody and satire oh
fair use
i thought it was just there are a lot of
people you know you know what happened
radiohead was able to give away their
music for free because they were super
rich yeah and so they were like let's
let's just
tell people to pay whatever they want
and then small businesses
people seem to think that the music the
music industry and the movie industry is
all blockbusters
as if the only movies that ever get made
are big hundred million dollar ventures
from disney
when in reality 99 of movies are small
low-budget films made by small
yeah there's definitely an irony going
on in media where not an irony but i
guess
it's just it seems counterintuitive
which is that as
the cost per minute of production of
content is going
way down like a camera that can produce
hd video is like 1 100 the cost it was
10 years ago
it's actually in hollywood it's
really being becoming vertically
integrated you know the netflix's and
all the big studios
are it basically has to be marketed
globally
like to china to all these massive
streaming audiences and the niche little
independent movies are actually
disappearing right so
i've i've known people who worked in the
movie industry i know people went to
college for movies and i know
what movie production is actually like
it's a large and massive industry of low
budget
small business medium-sized businesses
and the massive multinational
corporations that do
disney but just because disney is like
oh no we lost 100 million
off of our expected billion and everyone
goes who cares piracy isn't theft
and then my friend goes i lost my job
today and i'm like wow what happened
everybody pirated the movie we made we
couldn't make any money our money but
that's they don't know that that's the
no they do that's the excuse actually
crappy content my friend lost there i
don't care about that
you don't care about my friend and
losing their job because you're a thief
fine whatever if someone makes crappy
content and then they complain that it's
the pirates that made it so they weren't
able to sell their product
you know wake up you're you had a crap
product
you think you kept that room stealing
their content because it was they were
downloading it and checking it out and
they thought it sucked and it did suck
so it didn't sell why would they
download it if it sucked
because they wanted to find out if it
sucked or if it was good and then they
told their friends hey download it it
sucks well obviously not if it sucked
so then why were they downloading it to
see if it was good i just told you
so so so how come before piracy they
were able to market it and make money
and then afterwards people just said
oh uh i'm i think it sucks so i'll
download it anyway
ian that makes literally there's no
before and after there's no
example what movie came out before
piracy and after piracy there is none
well let's just use let's use um films
instead of music because i think there's
a kind of
a certain amount of capital required in
order to make a film that makes it a
little bit different from an album right
because you need more people to come
together to make a movie more money
right like okay so what's happening to
films right now
like independent the independent film
quote unquote business was much more
vibrant when everybody was arguing that
piracy was going to basically destroy
the film business
so why is it that piracy is much less of
an issue now
but technology solved the problem
independent film businesses technology
didn't solve the problem there are no
more good independent films
the sub 1 million budget films so like
things have become homogenized and
corporatized
in an era when you would think that it's
so cheap to make movies now
why why don't we have good more more
good small films it's not piracy
it's because multinational corporations
are controlling
basically the output of feature-length
films where is it where is that output
it's china china how do you watch the
movie
uh on a streaming something something
and so how does an independent uh
service
distribute their movies okay so
basically you'd have to sell it to one
of those streaming services and what if
they say no
then they they do that's what happens
now and so then where do you distribute
your movie after you made it
if the streaming platforms don't want it
china no nowhere your website your
website your website
nobody goes to your website to watch but
they know they did before
netflix the issue is
amazon netflix paramount make it so
easy to watch every movie but if you
aren't on those platforms and i've had i
had this happen i can't remember it's
not that hard to get on those platforms
though
it's just a question of whether or not
it's featured on the little browse
button
right well it's but you when i search
for like this there's like the same
thing on use like 50 hormones you can
post an amazing video to youtube and
nobody
freaking sees it because the the
algorithm doesn't put you in there you
there there are tons of people i know
who have pitched to amazon and said and
gotten turned down
and they all they they produce the movie
is this after the movie is produced or
is this like prior so
a lot of companies will produce a movie
and then pitch it for distribution some
companies will go to amazon for funding
specifically yes
and i know people who have pitched
amazon and got rejected yes that's
that's
the people who have then said we're
gonna distribute it through our website
and we're gonna do a promo campaign yeah
and then i know that people are like
i'll just download it for free
i just i don't i don't know i don't
necessarily agree or just don't watch it
because you're featuring it on your
website then people are going to pirate
it
yes i don't know i i
here's what i think i think that the
streaming services are the gatekeepers
yeah and whether or not you show up in
the algorithm and so you basically have
to be one of these 10
massive production companies and all the
smaller ones are either getting
swallowed up into that vertical
integration
or they're not you know they're not
getting on the algorithm so those are
the two options
yeah yeah so so why is that people chose
amazon over what they used to do with
with torrents and stuff like that
because it's easier so that's why i say
i think for the most part
it's been solved to a certain degree
like piracy has been very solved to a
certain degree
people still pirate that's what i'm
saying is it's been solved and you're
saying that piracy
hurts the little guy but what i'm saying
is actually the ease of the streaming
platforms
and the fact that like nobody has to go
and find them we started the
conversation by me saying the problem
has mostly been solved by streaming
services
but back during the height of piracy if
someone made
a movie and the budget was a hundred
grand and then you started
you downloaded it for free those people
could not make another movie
because instead of selling it what they
normally would have sold made money and
then filmed a sequel
people downloaded it i was i was at the
premiere for what we do in the shadows
and you know what's really funny about
what we do in the shadows you guys see
that movie it's um
uh what's the guy's name from taiko ytt
and jermaine clement i was there
at the premiere in new york city and
after it ended they're doing questions
and i raised my hand
and i said i'm gonna be honest with you
guys i already saw the movie
like it's all over the internet for free
does that
hurt your business and dude jermaine was
like
yes man it was a huge problem but he
doesn't know that's the problem because
those
none of those people that downloaded
mail and you're such an arrogant no but
you're
all there all those people see that
though if all those people see that like
don't you think that
you know that meant that entering the
popular consciousness because so many
people stole your movie there's a
certain currency associated with
occupying people's time
and you know them watching your content
like i if i put out a movie i'd be i'd
be like
oh you're telling me a million people
stole this and got it for free cool
that's a million people who saw my movie
and so are you making it as a hobby how
do you fund it i mean i think down the
road you can figure something out you
just
keep washing dishes until you i think
there's a i think there's a really easy
distinction here is that i've had a lot
of friends worked in history lose their
jobs and have their lives upended
because of what happened with piracy in
the 2000s
you don't and you don't care about them
no the entertainment industry is dead
now i was there i used to work in it
but i'm just arguing i'm saying i'm not
disagreeing that
they lost their jobs what i'm saying is
like seven years in tibet was 1997 and
that was the first movie
mgm made it and you know china was
the villain there and then after that
it got banned in china and they lost
hundreds of millions of dollars and ever
since then
we've been homogenizing and
corporatizing everything that goes
into theaters right that is my bad in my
opinion that homogenization has led to
less independent productions and but
that's but that's that's like we're
specifically
the question was brought up based on an
argument last week yeah where did we
even start
is piracy theft if you answer is yes it
is well no i mean that's your answer but
but it's but literally but does that
actually result in the in the crime
right what if what if you painted a
picture and someone took it and
stole it and then put it at in front of
the white house so 100 million people
saw it then everyone wanted to buy a
copy of it you became super rich
well so have you gone to new york yeah i
used to live there do you ever walk up
to somebody who's doing paintings in the
street
and what what do what do they have
written down next to their paintings
it's a sign
oh i don't know no photos right you know
why
because people want to sell their
original people take a picture of it and
then they don't make money
and then they can't paint anymore so but
we gotta well if you
if you if you get a hundred million
people that that copy you're a
pirate ian people aren't you're gonna be
fine people aren't
famous if you made a movie the movie
industry is not marvel
the movie industry are small
all regional films industry is marvel
now no it is
30 minutes with your friends and then a
hundred million people
pirates doesn't happen that is good for
you hey i have an idea
because you're going to be super
important if you buy a lottery ticket
you can win 100 million dollars
but the people i know who are working on
small productions for regional films and
going to art theaters who lost their
jobs people don't work by those dude
yes people don't buy art films ian you
are who
pays money to watch art films go to new
york go to houston
they have art theaters it was in this
genre for years yeah i agree but
i had friends who had jobs they had
lives
i used to work in the industry and you
don't care about well i mean
i acknowledge what's changed about the
industry i i have sympathy that they
lost a job you know i don't
all right chris rose 1986. john didn't
see that new art film
in the hospital when you were in labor
you the mother becomes second
the doctor will do everything to save
the baby first i have personally
experienced this with my labor because
my child was premature
interesting
frosty this is interesting the super
chat was actually from a while ago
before i made this point
using this logic on piracy taking a
photo of a painting is theft
in some capacities yes the native
americans said if you took their picture
they were stealing their soul
all right now that the argument has
completely subsumed
the uh i know this should have been the
theme of the show can we get like an ian
as a pirate like
a lion pirate can we get like a shirt we
need to say like oh god okay hold on no
it's a shirt but he's
ian is a pirate and he's saying i'm
going to steal your corn i am the
captain now
because ian ian i am a music composer
richie last week ian argued that he can
steal farmer's corn
i did not argue he did oh i used to do
that i grew up across the street
i did yeah and i used napster and i did
i stole the farm across the street
nice you're all over i did stole it but
are you familiar with the farmers what
seven years yeah it was more than seven
years ago it was like 20
something years ago so it's okay well
you admit it janette santana says ian
has no idea how the real world works
send him to cuba for one week with no
western union that was a very vague
statement
blackrock beacon is 42 years old for
christ blackrock vegan says bros making
copies is not piracy it's forgery
ian please read what i sent you on
mine's chat not enough room in super
chat to explain the rest it's forgery if
you're saying it's the original
if you're just copying it curtis
reynolds says i'm guessing ian steals
content every day that's why he's so
adamant that piracy isn't theft of
course it's theft
every act of piracy steals income from
the producer
wow blood on him of course it's theft
you literally have the blood of
oh no unemployed all musicians i i
ruined the music industry
it's true ian himself yeah by himself
says sorry ian if i work on something
with my brain
and you use it without compensation it
is stealing whether it's good or not
says who
says will i am says the u.s government
says the law that was written before
today let's change the law
all right let's see what's up will that
you know there used to be campaigns
telling people not to record the radio
because you could put a cassette tape on
and press record and they would be like
that was my childhood yeah yeah
double tape are you recording from the
radio then wait until kokomo from the
beach boys came on and hit record right
after it starts
the beginning of the song the issue is
everyone always says
well who cares about the rich people and
i'm like bro i don't i'm not talking
about them
i'm talking about the small businesses
that were destroyed by this i think
it's definitely different when you have
a small business and
and disney and the revenue drops because
of piracy
the small business goes that's yours
because of that
i'm not assuming it i there's been
studies that says to hang out in
columbia in chicago
the sales of products okay so i think
that's the best way you frame the
argument thus far which is
that you know basically like for example
with the shoplifting stuff like these
massive corporations can
deal with that they can absorb their
small business you can't absorb it
i i get that yep so if if you take away
20
of the margin from from small production
uh companies
and their margin is 18 they're out of
business you take away 20
from disney and they're like oh no i
guess we'll only make a billion dollars
this time
i just think it's more the kind of um
the corporatization
of art music films
just over the course of american history
to become more and more corporate
regardless of the cost per minute of
video and so like
the same group thing that we see in the
news is happening in hollywood
and like you know but they're the tim
pools and you know i think there are new
independent filmmakers out there
who i think there will be a new
hollywood new one here i got to read
this one's great arias raffle
cal says tell us the name of your
friend's movie or it's fake so
i'm 35 years old when i was 18
and used to hang out at columbia in
chicago with like
a a network of 30 or so people who were
doing various music and film industry
stuff
and then when i was 20 i had friends be
like i lost my job and like a bunch of
them lost their jobs
like yeah i don't know the names of all
the movies they were working on
or the albums they were producing it
happened
anyway thanks for hanging out we have a
bonus segment though so if you want to
hear more rage and
maybe i'll flip the table over yeah you
know you know we'll do the new studio is
a few weeks away from being done
we'll just film ourselves office spacing
the whole studio and just no we won't do
that we're gonna still use the studio
uh go to simcast.com become a member
we're gonna have a bonus segment coming
up like this
video subscribe to this channel you can
follow us you know what i don't even
tell you to follow us because we have a
new we have new graphics so i'm not even
you just follow follow us at tim cast
irl
follow me at tim cast and uh go to
10ks.com richie
you have stuff um okay at richie
mcginnis r-i-c-h-i-e-m-c-g-i-n-n-i-s-s
and also last time i came on here i did
a plug
for an intern job on the video squad and
i told everyone to email richie
dailycolor.com
but this time we need a media reporter
and you're going to email
jeff dailycolor.com and because we got
some great applicants last time and
shout out to juan who's on the vid squad
now
if you like to clip crazy moments in
cable news you like memes and you like
drinking beer
jeff g-e-o-f-f daily caller.com
jeff jean that's free and he would
definitely
not be happy if he called him and he's a
big marine i had a friend
named jeff was by the way
uh hey i'm you follow me ian crossland
party on
nice the pirate yes the pirate follow
the pirate you guys they follow me as
well
no go ahead oh oh yeah i had a little
bit more i was going to say you guys
have to help me get more followers and
sour patch kids
because that's my goal in life and it
would mean a lot to me we got to make
the ian pirate shirt
yes it's going to be him my favorite
alien tim fight of all time corn
i used to work at it a grocery store and
i would write the announcements and then
record them for the store and i created
the acme pirate
you talk like that do it somebody's a
sale an aisle too
somebody said the liquid gold
all right we'll wrap it up there you're
scurvy go to timcast.com
we'll see you all over there smash that
like button thanks for hanging out bye
guys
you